before we begin our hearings this
morning chairman Hamilton joins me in
this sad duty to report that William
Casey former director of Central
Intelligence died this morning
in the coming weeks as all inquiry on
falls mr. Casey's name will be heard
frequently in regard to the iran-contra
affair whatever may be the final
judgment of his role in this event it
should not obscure mr. Casey's
distinguished record of commitment to
this country from the Office of
Strategic Services to the Securities and
Exchange Commission to the Central
Intelligence Agency
mr. Casey served his nation with
dedication purpose and energy the record
will show that once again we have mr.
Thomas green accompanying our witness
mr. seacord mr. seacord
this is to remind you that you're still
under the oath mr. Neal's please proceed
mr. chairman at the outset Island
request that the first four exhibits
exhibits marked numbers one through four
be made a part of the record of this
hearing
the secret before we get back to the
story you testified yesterday that the
lake resources account received a
deposit of a million dollars in November
of 1985 you indicated that that was
several happened several days after you
arrived in Portugal and that it was
advance payment of transportation
expenses I think you also indicated that
it was not part of your job to take care
of transportation until several days
after you arrived in Lisbon we have
reviewed the bank records provided by
mr. Hakim and they reflect that the
million dollars was deposited on
November the 20th which you had
testified yesterday was the day on which
you arrived in Portugal can you give us
any explanation of that
yes mr. Nields my recollection was as I
testified yesterday it's of course
possible that the matter of
transportation that was discussed a few
days earlier than that in my initial
discussions with oliver north
i don't recall it but it's possible that
that could have occurred and north could
have been in touch with mr. swimmer a
few days earlier than i recalled I don't
have any records of that timeframe
Jassi court yesterday you had just
finished telling us about a transaction
in which while you were in Portugal you
arranged for the transportation of 80
Hawk missiles from Tel Aviv to Teheran
they were to go 18 approximately per
plane and that there were to be four or
five plane loads I think you also
testified that after the first plane
containing 18 Hawk missiles arrived in
Teheran the Iranians or so you heard
indicated that they were the wrong type
of weapons and they didn't want any more
and that you then went to Israel to do
an investigation and find
what had happened and I think you told
us that when you got there you learned
from the Israelis that the Iranians had
wanted missiles that would shoot down
high-flying planes and at these Hawk
missiles who were built for low-flying
planes or lower flying planes that's
correct
before we go on with the story I'd like
to ask you who in the United States
government was aware to your knowledge
that Hawk missiles were being shipped to
Iran in November of 1985 mr. McFarlane
so I was informed by Oliver North was
aware Oliver North of course was aware
certain officials in the Central
Intelligence Agency became aware I know
this because they were communicating
with their field office in Portugal and
I personally informed a senior CIA
official in Lisbon of the nature of the
cargo I don't know whether he knew that
in advance or not because of course I
didn't see their cable traffic but I
would be certain that he reported that
back to his headquarters anyone else I
don't believe that there are any others
that I was aware of I take it you're
including mr. north yes of course when
you were in Israel did you learn
anything else when you had your meetings
with Israeli officials there was there
was one other issue that was raised by
the Israelis during my discussions with
them in the Ministry of Defence that was
the issue of previous delivery of 508
tow missiles from Israel
Iran they assumed that I knew of this
earlier delivery which took place I
believe in August in September and two
tranches 100 and 400 but in fact I did
not know of this so this was news to me
the reason why the issue was raised with
me was because the Israeli officials in
the Ministry of Defense knew that I was
very knowledgeable of the u.s. rules
regulations and laws with respect to
foreign military sales they told me that
they had been assured that these 508
missiles would be replenished by the
United States which didn't particularly
surprise me but what did bother me was
the assertion that mr. McFarlane had
assured them that these would be
replenished free of charge in other
words the Israelis were not expected to
pay for these missiles through the
normal foreign military sales channels I
told the director-general of Ministry of
Defense that I believed that he had a
communications problem because I knew of
course there was no statutory authority
for such a move you know I was not
thinking of the CIA Channel at that time
I was thinking of the normal foreign
military sales channel I suggested that
they that the way to handle it was to
reprogram their existing foreign
military sales credits and procure those
items through their u.s. procurement
office in the normal fashion they said
no that was not not the case at all that
that I was wrong that in fact they had
been assured that these missiles would
be replenished - free of charge
I said replenishment can can mean
different things and I really believed
that your own you should talk to bud
McFarlane about this we left it at that
I later reported this to north and to
mr. MacFarland personally before we
before we get to that mr. seacord
what did you do after you'd had these
conversations with the Israelis in which
you found out what the problem was with
the Hawk missiles did you report back to
your people in Washington yes I reported
this back to north and both he and the
Israelis suggested that I go on from
Israel
to Europe to meet with mr. Gurbani for
whom I had never met before
now mr. seacord at this point in time I
take it there are now 18 hawk missiles
in Teheran which the Iranians don't want
that is correct the hostages have not
been released
correct how about money has any money
passed hands to your knowledge at this
point in time I was told that
substantial sums of money were
transferred from Gurbani far to mr.
swimmers company I didn't know the the
amounts of money it was strictly an
Israeli transaction I did not know how
much money was involved I was advised by
the Ministry of Defense however that
they had received no money as of that
time four of these tow missiles what is
the to your knowledge what is the status
at this point in time when you go to
Paris what is the status of the project
is it is it dead is it in limbo is is it
gonna move forward I didn't know it your
word limbo probably best characterizes
it it was not clear to me whether it was
dead or not the Israel the Iranians were
very very unhappy with with these
missiles being there and they wanted
them out that was all that I knew for
sure in any event you went to Paris and
you had a meeting yes who did you meet
with I met with mr. gorban fr and he was
accompanied by Jakob número
Israeli citizen I met with them in Paris
what was mr. numero DS role mr. newm
rody was an associate of business
associate of Mr Al Schwimmer did you
talk about what had happened or did you
talk about what was going to happen we
talked about what had happened and gore
Boni far engaged me and quite a bit of
conversation about how he thought the
game should continue in the future he
had a number of proposals in mind which
were interesting I took notes on these
and later of course reported it well the
essence of my discussions with Gore
bonny far too north I was I was in no
position to negotiate any kind of deal
with with with Gore bonny far or with
anyone else so I was basically in a
receive mode what were mr. Govan affairs
proposals his proposals all of were
various sets of arms for hostage
proposals he was very interested in what
I would characterize as us high
technology weapons systems specifically
Phoenix missile systems for their f-14s
harpoon missiles other air intercept
missiles were mentioned a few times and
tow missiles and even though the eye
hawk missiles were sitting on the ground
in Iran and he knew that they were not
wanted he still talked from time to time
about a shipping eye Hawk missiles he
came up with different formulas so many
phoenixes for so many boxes as he called
them which was his codeword for hostages
it was blatantly set of proposals
of arms for hostages he had a
boilerplate kind of salesmanship patter
which he put out very very glibly which
talked about the strategic setting and
things that he knew Americans would like
to hear the Russian threat the Iranians
were being held hostage by the hostages
and themselves and so on they needed to
move on but it was my impression that
korban fr was more interested in
business than he was in in foreign
policy
did you reach any kind of an agreement
during these meetings no and I was not
in a position I won't agree Minh Thuy
reached was an agreement to meet in
London because I was reporting back to
north and I was informed that they had
agreed with the Israelis to meet in
London they north and later turned out
that mr. McFarlane came to London as
well
it was the approximate date of the
meeting in Paris it would be the first
week of December and did their did you
go to a meeting in London yes I had some
other business to see - in Paris for for
a day or two and then travelled to
London to meet with the Israelis and mr.
gorban fr and the approximate date and
my recollection of that day was probably
about the sixth or so of a December that
I went to went to London who did you
meet with and I met with again with mr.
numero D mr. Gore bonny far mr.
Schwimmer had come up from Israel by
this time and he was in in the meetings
and mr. Kim key also arrived in London
for the meetings where did the meeting
take place it took place in numero DS
townhouse near Hyde Park
in London I take it this is a meeting at
which mr. north and mr. McFarlane were
not present that's correct
I with all these people the day before
North arrived and talked about a
possible agenda although no agenda was
ever written out or agreed to we just
talked about how the meeting should be
approached I did not know at the time
that mr. McFarlane was coming I think I
was notified by north after he arrived
after who arrived after North arrived in
London before we get to Norse arrival
what happened at the meeting with the
Israelis in Gorgon afar again we went
over briefly what had happened but the
probable problem was and then listened
to Gore bonny fire and NIM Rodina
Maroney was actively engaged in this
talk about how one could proceed in the
future I mean they were getting
themselves prepared to talk with North
the US official and they wanted to
proceed they wanted to keep the game
going they wanted to continue in their
dealings with Iran and they were seeking
ways in which they could continue their
for several different ideas were were
tossed around again though it they
always revolved around these high
technology systems which only the United
States could supply and of course Israel
could supply toes but Israel doesn't
have harpoons Israel does not have a
phoenix missiles so well it was it would
require direct involved in the United
States I didn't have any power to
negotiate a thing but I wasn't hesitant
to inform those people that it was my
judgment that there was very little
chance that the United States would
agree to transfer anything as sensitive
as a as a Phoenix or a harpoon missile
to Iran I couldn't do I couldn't see how
that could ever happen
so I advised them of that but they
still kept it in there in their heads
and of course they did bring it up at
the meetings take it you were there at
the request of mr. north
yes and what was the purpose what was
the purpose for you being there I think
he wanted me to collect excuse me
collect all the information that I could
in advance of the meeting advise him on
what their positions were and I did this
I take it a day or so later mr. North
arrived yes and I would put that
approximately the 7th 6th or 7th of
December he arrived did you report to
him I did and was there a separate
meeting between mr. North and gore
Vaughn afar and the Israelis before mr.
McFarlane arrived not to my recollection
I don't think that North met with him
until McFarlane arrived he was waiting
for he was collecting information
preparing for mr. McFarlane to arrive
and he he informed me that mr. McFarlane
himself was coming and did mr. McFarlane
in fact come yes he did he arrived he
arrived I believe on the about the 8th
of December in the morning he came by a
US Air Force special mission aircraft we
met in the hotel near Hyde Park North
conferred with him privately for a while
and then I met with mr. McFarlane and
gave him a rehash of what I'd been
reporting to North to prepare him for
the meeting we then proceeded to the
meeting and I believe it was early
afternoon that the meeting started
that's my recollection at least mr.
McFarlane
and I and our North went to the meeting
together by taxicab and met with all the
others that I've mentioned earlier upon
arrival McFarland and Kim key conferred
privately for for a short time and there
was a bit of a dispute that erupted out
of his hearing amongst several of the
Israelis it was a pretty interesting as
to who was essentially to be in control
whether it was to be Schwimmer or a
general who had come down from the
Ministry of Defence but then McFarland
came how did that how did that work out
well it it worked out with Schwimmer
asserting that he was in control and
rather than continue the dispute in
front of Americans they they calmed it
down and it did not become an issue it
was a silly issue to begin with because
the ensuing discussions were entirely
between MacFarlane Gore bonny far and
mr. Kim key occasionally commented would
you describe the discussions briefly yes
the the meeting went on for quite a long
while several hours and there was it was
badly it was badly sighted I may say
because they had mr. McFarlane seated at
a table smaller than this directly
across from mr. Grove on a farm and they
were practically nose-to-nose throughout
this entire session and then the rest of
us were seated around the room
essentially listening MacFarlane said
that he was there too to listen to what
had happened and to listen to any
proposals that they might have
korban fr ran through again the whole
litany of things that I have mentioned
to you here today he started out with
his overview his strategic setting and
he had as I said it was very good I've
heard he make that address several times
it almost has like a tape and he you
know but very quickly very quickly that
meeting degenerated it it degenerated
into propositions of us arms for US
hostages in Lebanon
korban fr pursued that that line with
mr. McFarlane for a long time far too
long I was glad when the meeting was
over and McFarlane was very unhappy very
very unhappy with this session he told
me are you now referring to something
that happened after the meeting yes he
told me after the meeting that it was
very unhappy but it was apparent in the
meeting itself I mean no no US official
could agree to such such a proposition
what did he say at the meeting he said
he would report this information back to
the president he committed to nothing he
didn't didn't say you would do anything
or wouldn't do anything he just left how
long did the meeting last it lasted
several hours maybe three four hours I
don't remember if it was too long it
just went on and on and korban FR was
making his best salesman pitch what did
you do after the meeting
taxi back to the hotel picked up the
bags and went straight to the London
Airport whereupon we all departed for
Washington Andrews Air Force Base in the
US Air Force plane the three of us came
back that night together and so I had
opportunity to toss this around with mr.
McFarlane and with Colonel North on the
way home
and we conferred quite a bit what did
what did you say what did they say
well McFarland said that this was one of
the most despicable characters he'd ever
met I found that kind of an interesting
comment because he was far for the most
despicable character I've ever met that
he been let's make sure we know that
we're talking about decease to our
district or Bonaparte
what subject was mr. gore bonny far if
not the most despicable character you've
ever met nonetheless despicable the
argumentation he was advancing was
repulsive to all of us there's no
question about that but Galvani far is
smooth and he says he's a Salesman and I
mean he he was on the wrong line but he
was making a hard pitch and he was he
had a lot of tenacity and he he just he
just wouldn't stop korban e far wanted
as I've said twice before the game to
continue that was his objective he may
have posed as an agent of Iran but he
was really his own agent he was a
businessman he was interested in making
money and that was it so I didn't argue
with with mr. McFarlane on that point I
did however since in my discussions with
him that the Iranian initiative was dead
you know this this seemed to me to be
the case I've made a counter argument
with him and wrote a short handwritten
point paper for him on the airplane it
was my position then and it had been for
a long time that we had essentially a
blank in our strategic planning for for
that area since the revolution in Iran
we had nothing in Iran we had no idea of
what was going on in Iran we had no
relations with Iran yet it was a vitally
strategic piece of territory which is
unique in the world it seemed to me that
if we
didn't try to do something to regain a
measure of influence or at least
relations with Iran then the Soviets
surely would over time achieve a
powerful sphere of influence there and
the where that would lead
no one could tell in the Defense
Department
I wrote papers on this subject I
attended interagency meetings on this
subject and all we ever did that seemed
to me was wring our hands and and say
it's a terrible situation we never did
anything did you convince mr. McFarlane
with your arguments oral and written on
the airplane no did you talk to mr.
McFarlane about anything else on the
airplane of note I mentioned to
McFarlane my my meetings with the
Israelis in in Tel Aviv and I mentioned
that to him when I gave him my first
briefing in the hotel but then we talked
about it on the way home and I mentioned
to him again the replenishment of the
508 toes which the Ministry of Defense
had brought to my attention but he
wasn't in a mood to talk about those he
was those items he was non-committal not
particularly concerned about it and so
so I dropped it did he say anything
about on that plane trip about the
approval or any approval by this country
for that for that transaction the
shipment yes he is right at the toes yes
I told him in the course of the of our
discussions that I of course had not
even known there was any toe transaction
in in August and September and and he
told me that that he did know of it of
course and he said in in fact the
president approved it in July of 1985
before we leave these toes had you
talked with anyone other than MacFarlane
about the Israeli claim
MacFarlane had promised to replenish the
toes for free all over North when when
he first arrived in in London and I may
even have mentioned on the telephone but
I don't think in any detail because it's
not the kind of subject you want to talk
about on the telephone and I take it you
told him that the Israelis claimed that
there was such a promise and that you
thought there was a communication
problem on many occasions I made that
point and what was mr. North's I was
saying I was I was hinting to them that
that was the line that they ought to
take that there was indeed a
communications problem because to me it
was a simple problem if the Israelis
would reprogram but it was a big problem
if they expect the Defense Department to
ship from stocks because it's not
possible what did mr. North say he said
he would check it out did he ever tell
you whether there was a promise to
replenish for free yes but not at this
time it was later I believe in January
when what did he tell you then on that
subject he said that that I was wrong
that there was no communications problem
that there had and there had in fact
been an assurance given to the Israeli
Ministry of Defence that these missiles
would be replaced the free of charge
before we finish the this trip home did
you have any understanding as of that
time about where the money was for the
the Hawks that had not been shipped to
Iran I had a vague understanding because
there was some discussion of the money
in the margins I didn't know numbers but
there had been some transactions taking
place in Geneva between the Iranian
officials among Iranian officials
Gurbani far and mr. newm rowdy and this
you'd heard about at the various
meetings that you did in the margins but
I couldn't been a specificity to it and
you had you heard in general that there
had been some kind of a refund from the
Elysee to the tagore bonafide there had
been and apparently there had been a
quick refund of a certain amount of
money when the Iranians were rejecting
these 18 missiles and of course the deal
was originally for 80 missiles remember
not for 18 so your understanding was
that Gabbana Farhad originally paid for
80 and that 18 had been shipped and when
they asked that the others not be
shipped there was a refund for the
unshipped Hawks that was my general
understanding of the situation as it
stood at that time when you get back
from London on the plane with MacFarlane
and North what was your understanding
with respect to this project that the
project was finished terminated did you
ride home with oliver north from the
airport yes
we got a ride downtown and then he gave
me a lift
dropped me at my house on the way home
that night and we chatted about a bit
and and he too believed that it was that
it was finished the and I had no further
discussions about this throughout
December the tower report is incorrect
in its statement that I had many
meetings later in December on that
to the subject before we pick up I take
it you did have some meetings in January
yes sir before we pick up on those I
want to follow some money for a moment
you testified that you got in November a
million dollars the purpose of which was
transportation costs that I take it
would have covered the five shipments
which were contemplated at that time and
only one occurred does that mean that
you spent substantially less than the
full million dollars on transportation
yes we spent I think was a about a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
the 707 operator and another sum of
money for a leased Lear jet so
altogether of less than two hundred
thousand dollars was expended in support
of that project so more than eight
hundred thousand which had been put in
by the Israelis remained in lake
resources that's correct
what happened to that money well I
assumed that they would ask for their
money back but they didn't and I've
discussed this with north also and later
I believe late December he told me that
they were not going to ask for it back
and we could use it for whatever purpose
we wanted we actually expended it on the
contra project did you and and north
discuss the fact that you would spend it
on the contra project yes did he
indicate where the idea came from to use
it for the contra project I think it was
his idea
did he give any indication that he
discussed this with the Israelis no he
told me he discussed it with the
Israelis but not as to destination of
the funds so so mr. Schwimmer made a
contribution
well let that one sink in for a minute
mr. seacord i think you've said that
there came a time in January when you
did have some further discussions on the
subject of Iran yes sir I take it
actually there was that one brief
meeting in December with the director
Casey in which he was talking about Iran
and you were talking about Nicaragua
other than that I take it you had no
discussions with anyone after you got
off that that plane in December no until
January that's correct okay tell us what
happened in January well I thought as I
said I thought that the project was was
finished aborted and I didn't even think
about it
but in early January I received a call
and this I can't put a date on it but it
was just for illustrative purposes let's
say maybe around the 10th or 12th 13th
somewhere along in there of January I
received a call from Admiral Poindexter
I was asked if I could drop by and I did
that evening what was Admiral
Poindexter's position at that time he
was the newly appointed national
security adviser he had replaced mr.
McFarlane replaced mr. McFarlane I
believe on the first start in the 1st of
January I went to his office in the
White House and spent some time with him
that evening the meeting probably lasted
45 minutes or an hour but he was
interrupted a number of times by phone
calls he had his aide commander Thompson
with him it was in and out of the
meeting from time to time Admiral
Poindexter thanked me he said he was
very appreciative for the service I had
rendered and and for what I was doing he
of course was making reference to both
the contra project and to the short trip
I had taken Portugal Israel Europe in
November and December he said that they
had been in touch with the Israeli
officials again that the president had
decided to try a new initiative toward
Iran he wanted to know if I would be
willing to help them in executing this
initiative he said they had been
impressed by what I had done earlier
when I'd run my short inquiry on the on
the hawk problem and I said to him at
the time that this thing had appeared to
be from Corbin a farce
presentation mm-hmm a swap of American
arms for American hostages in Lebanon
and you know that that to me was not
acceptable and I thought he knew that
and he said that this was an entirely
new initiative and he explained it to me
and I'll hit those points in just a
second and he said that this was not
going to be and he agreed with me we
couldn't live with the arms for a
hostage swap this was not going to be
won this initiative was founded on
strategic objectives which were
basically to achieve some sort of
dialogue with the Iranian government to
make contact with a so called and excuse
me so called moderate elements or what I
call the pragmatic elements in there
right in the Iranian government and to
press forward with this initiative in a
covert way in an attempt to make a
breakthrough conventional methods had
not yielded anything and hopefully to
persuade the Iranians to you
their influence to release the hostages
being held by Shia factions in Lebanon I
said I would be honored to try to do
what I could and that pretty well
summarizes the meeting that took place
that night you've indicated that he said
it was not going to be arms for hostages
hostages were mentioned I take it indeed
then one should mention several times
and there's no secret there was great
concern in the White House about these
hostages many avenues have been pursued
to try to get them released and there's
no question now there won't anybody to
misunderstand me there's no question
that the hostages were an important
element in this initiative no question
at all
where arms mentioned yes what was said
about arms specific arms were not
discussed at this meeting whether it be
toes or this or that
but he said that they were convinced
that small amounts of arms could be used
as successfully as bona fides in this
initiative what was it that agreed by
the way what was it that you were being
asked to do it wasn't clear at that time
he just asked if I'd be willing to help
and and I said yes and I was shortly
invited to another meeting in which my
role became much more clear where was
that meeting that meeting was also held
in the White House in the Situation Room
who invited you and I was invited by
Admiral Poindexter's office I don't
remember whether he told me that night
there was going to be a meeting or I got
a phone call a day or two later but any
case it was his office which invited me
to the meeting who was at the meeting at
this meeting which was I thought about
the 16th of February but I note that the
tower report has it a few days later I
think I don't know
exactly
at this meeting where the then general
counsel of the CIA mr. sporkin he had
one or two attorneys with him from his
office the deputy director CIA for
operations mr. Clair George the chief or
the deputy chief of the Near East
section of CIA was present and also
present were North I should point out
that mr. North where Colonel North was
not present in the meeting between
Poindexter and I but North wasn't at the
Situation Room meeting commander
Thompson was in the meeting also see a
lawyer he is a lawyer he's a naval
officer but he's a lawyer what was the
subject of the meeting the subject I
thought the meeting was peculiar because
I didn't really know why I was there
because they were discussing the finding
I had been told earlier by Admiral
Poindexter there was going to be a
finding of course there would have to be
if there was going to be a covert
operation and the finding the
presidential finding the order
initiating this covert action was this
was the main subject at this meeting
why were you a private citizen invited
to a meeting with apparently a number of
lawyers who were putting together a
presidential finding yeah I thought the
finding together and they were
discussing it and I thought that they
were discussing certain language and
later reports indicate that that finding
may have already been typed and final at
that point
I don't recall because it was kind of an
academic discussion as far as I was
concerned but was it a signed finding
you were talking about there or a draft
of it I don't I don't think the science
was signed when I saw it I only got a
chance to read one paragraph of it and I
don't recall seeing the president's
signature on it which is why I put the
meeting on or before the 17th because it
was signed on the 17th was there
discussion of changes or possible
changes in the findings there was a
discussion of one change that had been
made in which they inserted into the
language that in addition to the normal
action agencies that the government
would work through third parties and
third countries and that's why I was at
the meeting I was the third party I was
to be the commercial cutout if you will
there was their intention to in some
respects mirror the previous Israeli
operation the previous Israeli operation
dealt from the Israeli government
through an Israeli company to an Iranian
commercial operator ghorm on a fire and
then to the government of Iran and it
was in that fashion that the Israelis
dealt with the matter what is the what
was the purpose for a commercial cutout
as you put it the government's involved
Israel in the United States could not
deal directly with the government of
Iran why not well they have been
unsuccessful and in establishing any
kind of relations and they couldn't deal
with I mean we are the Great Satan there
was no way that that the governments
could overtly deal one with the other
even if they wanted to at that point was
this a legal problem or a public
relations problem I think it was a
public relations problem primarily and I
think that the structure did in that
fashion in order to be able to in a
practical way deal with Iran were there
legal issues that were discussed at this
meeting yes whether or not to notify the
Congress and
and how it would be done or when it
would be done it was discussed that
there was a legal precedent for delaying
notification I was at the time not very
familiar with the with the laws
pertaining to the Central Intelligence
Agency since I never dealt with those
when I was in the Pentagon so I was
simply a listener at that point
additionally it was decided that the
United States and this was a very
important point the United States would
have to directly ship the weapons rather
than taking them from Israeli stocks and
they decided that they would have to do
this because of the various statutes
that apply to the sale of arms and it
was decided by the lawyers that the
Economy Act would have to be utilized
whereby one agency and the US government
can purchase from another agency and so
the plan was for the CIA to buy the
materials from the Defense Department
stocks and then to sell them to my
organization which in turn would sell
them to a Gurbani fire who in turn would
sell them to Iran that was the that was
the the plan and that's the way the plan
was executed for the first several
transactions just to be certain as the
plan was discussed did the Israelis have
any part in it at all yes it was a joint
venture if you will the Israelis were to
provide the
base from which to to ship a secure base
and they were also to provide cover it
was planned that part of the cover for
this operation would be that if it were
discovered that the Israelis could take
the hit if you will were the sales to go
through Israel in any way in other words
was his was Israel at any time going to
take position and ownership of the arms
know was that a change from some
previous plan yes it was previously that
appeared they had discussed a plan with
the Israelis whereby the Israelis would
in fact either ship from their own
inventories and later to be replenished
from us inventories or would buy from
the US and then we ship that was
originally the plan but they abandoned
that plan for whatever reasons the
lawyers had and came up with a new plan
just so we understand the role of the
commercial cutout which I think you have
described as being yours is that correct
correct I think you indicated that
neither Israel nor the United States
could sell directly to Iran and I think
you've said that that wasn't a a legal
problem it was some other kind of
problem
precisely from whom was this plan
designed to keep the fact that the
United States would be selling to Iran
from whom well it was who was involved
in the planning now let me reframe it I
take it both the United States and
officials in Iran knew that the United
States was selling arms to Iran right
okay the commercial cutout was designed
in order to conceal that fact yes from
whom from the Iranians anyone else
No
how about the Congress if that was
intended it was never discussed in my in
my presence I don't think that was their
plan I think that they were interested
in concealing it from Iran only now when
you say Iran there were government
officials in Iran who were of course
aware very few but there were some and
there was it was a very delicate matter
for these people and there were a few
government officials in the United
States who were aware yes now was the
commercial cut out in part designed to
make sure that only a small number of
people in the United States were aware
possibly but I hadn't considered that
point before you just now raised it it's
it's possible and then in the case of
Israel you said it was designed to
mirror the way it had been handled
previously in Israel from for what
purpose was the commercial cut out
devised in the transactions between
Israel and Iran clearly to enable the
Israelis to deal with with Iran it's
even more difficult for the Israelis to
deal with Iran and than for the United
States
there could be no no hint officially
that Israel was dealing with Iran and
therefore they had to form a commercial
relationship you're saying I take it
that the fact that Israel was selling to
Iran had to be concealed from Iranians
yes how about from Israelis I don't
think that entered into their calculus
but I can't speak for them I can only
tell you what I believe
staying on the subject of the commercial
cutout was it part of the purpose of the
commercial cutout to create profit for
the commercial enterprise we did not go
into this enterprise I did not go into
this enterprise with the notion of
making profit as time went on we right
Nick right now I'm just asking we'll get
back to to what happened later but right
now I'm just asking about the purpose at
the time for including a commercial cut
out there was there was no intention of
profiteering I know that some people
were tossing this word around right now
and I resent it there was no intention
of profiteering none was there any
discussion of profit no any discussion
of mark-up there was a lot of discussion
about markup because in order to make it
work I had I had to mark up the prices
in order to pay for all the the overhead
involved I'm talking now about the the
meeting that you had in which you were
discussing the finding and discussing
the way the transaction would be struck
there was no discussion of that I take
it you're saying that there were later
discussions of markup in the context
among other things of covering your
expenses that's correct and I take it
what you're saying is that the
commercial enterprise not only paid a
purchase price for the arms but also had
to pay dispenses involved in
transporting them and delivering them
that's correct
I take it that either explicitly or
implicitly at this meeting at which the
finding was discussed that you agreed to
serve as a commercial cutout that is
correct
I did not feel that I was a part of the
government in any way that it was
clearly a commercial operation and I
take it there were some transactions
which followed yes sir and I take it you
had some meetings in which those
transactions were discussed and agreed
upon that's correct
what was the next meeting after the one
in which you discussed the finding well
there were several meetings that I was
involved in with first with Colonel
north and then later with some logistics
officials and some operational officials
from the CIA I was informed subsequent
to this meeting in this situation room
that I've described for you that a new
Israeli official had been appointed to
be in charge of this operation this who
was that this man was a maram near from
the Prime Minister's office in Israel I
was told that in very early January
mr. near had come to Washington held
discussions with Colonel North and with
John Poindexter and also with mr.
McFarlane to who informed you of this
Colonel north he was given he was
reading me in into the the situation
after this meeting in the Situation Room
would it be fair to say that from then
on mr. north was your principal contact
the United States government indeed
did I was also told that in earlier in
January around the 11th to the 13th of
January mr. gorban afar had been invited
to come to Washington although I didn't
see him and he was given a polygraph
exam which as usual he did you
eventually nonetheless have a meeting
with mr. gorban fr and others in London
in a January yes yes indeed would that
be the 22nd and 23rd of January correct
1986 yes
prior to that time had you been made
aware of any negotiations with the
Iranians and furtherance of this
initiative
I'd been made aware that there were
discussions between north and gorban FR
when he was here in washington that
there had been a lot of discussions
between north and near on the telephone
but other than that i don't know of any
negotiations were you aware that during
those negotiations arms had been
discussed yes were you aware of the type
by this time I was told that it had been
decided and authorized by the president
that 4000 tow missiles would be
available for this initiative just
briefly for the record what is a tow
missile tow missile was a as a wire
guided missile for principally for
anti-tank type work were you told that
there have been any discussions of price
yes I was I was told that when gorban fr
was here for his polygraph tests that he
had suggested that the price for the
toes and he'd been told the toes were
going to be involved that the price for
the toes should be ten thousand five
hundred dollars per toe that his profit
would be $500 per toe so he said
although we had evidence I'd learned
later that that he probably charged far
more than that in the earlier
transactions he said that this should be
the price because this was the price he
charged during the Israeli transactions
in August in September 1985 was he the
one who mentioned this price or was this
a or was it north or someone from this
side I was told by north that the gore
body fire brought it up and near later
confirmed that to me because he had
talked to korban a fire also so he had
offered a price of ten thousand dollars
sometime before your meeting in London
yes and had you been told that there had
been any discussion of hostages yes
there were always discussions of
hostages whenever there were meetings
with Gurbani fire or the Iranians and
what was your understanding of the
agreements of force it related to
hostages or the status of the
negotiations on that subject yet to be
defined who attended the meeting in
London I attended the meeting in London
Oliver North and Romney R and mr. gorban
fr what was discussed there at this time
gore gore banach far raised the subject
in front of north and i with near that
he was still owed 5.4 million dollars
what was that force was had to do with
the hawk the eye hawk transaction
remember the Hawks are still sitting in
Tehran the Iranians are still demanding
that they be removed he raised this with
near in front of us because he hoped to
get some kind of support from us
in this dispute with mr. near did he
know what else happened it did did mr.
near agree to return the money he said
that they were working on it I later
learned that they did return the money
just although this is out of sequence
did you do you also know whether the 18
missiles were returned yes they were
returned in the first and our first
transaction with Iran and I cover that
in February what else occurred at this
meeting several things at at this
meeting the Israeli representative
demanded that their 508 toe problem be
solved he wanted to know how it was
going to be solved that is how were we
going to furnish them with 508 toes
without Israel having to pay for them
this was an issue between the Israelis
and the Americans only I take it that's
correct all right what happened it was
not mentioned in gurbani fires presence
well this was an issue that that that
Israel wanted an assurance on from from
north and so it was decided that
sufficient monies would be collected in
the sale of these 4,000 toes to enable
me to purchase four thousand four
hundred or four thousand five hundred
and eight toes thus we were going to
collect sufficient funds along the way
to offset the purchase of these weapons
for Israel
returning to the transaction between the
Americans and the Iranians the future
transaction what was said about that at
this meeting that was discussed that we
would have to get from Iran some sort of
plan on how we were to proceed with the
initiative an agreed plan it was high on
the
agenda of the American side to achieve a
high level government-to-government
meeting with Iranian officials
korban fr is not an Iranian official
korban a fire took this request and said
that he would pursue it with his contact
in the office of the Prime Minister in
Israel I also passed the lake resources
account number and address to Mister
near at this first meeting this was the
first time I met mr. near we did not
settle the price finally at this meeting
although we talked about the price being
ten million dollars this is what Gurbani
fire had offered and this is what I
wanted to collect I had not yet priced
out my operation there was a lot of
uncertainty in this operation at this
time we went back to what was said about
hostages at the meeting it was discussed
that the hostages was an issue that we
had to get around and get passed to Gore
bonny fire used his line that Iran too
wanted to settle this problem they
because Iran was being held hostage by
the hostages but there were no I don't
recall any specific plan being arrived
at at this meeting was a plan arrived at
at some time later between the Americans
and the Iranians yes it was when on the
six that we agreed to meet again that's
that's that's about all we really agreed
to at this first meeting in London we
agreed to meet again after having vetted
some of the problems on the 6th of
February we were supposed to meet again
in London north and I both traveled
there and so did mr. near but mr. Govan
afar did not show that there come a
later time when you reached an agreement
with the Iranians yes but this was done
done my telephone between near or Boni
far and north and I take it it was
reported to you yes it was I was after I
was kept advised I think
completely and would this have been in
the next week or so after the meeting
that it was shortly after near stayed
behind in London trying to locate korban
a far north and I returned home and near
did locate Corbin fr and it was it was
normal Gurbani far we found a normal
pattern for him if he had problems he
would be a no-show I mean he would
disappear go off the scope and whenever
he had problems so we could tell when he
had problems
we just couldn't contact him whenever he
thought he had a problem solved and of
course he'd be back up on the loop again
and though he'd be back in touch with
him I was in touch with Corbin fr couple
occasions in February by telephone and
we on one of these occasions I kind of
burned my bridges with mr. gorban fr
because I was very angry with him he had
made a deposit to the credit Swiss bank
which bounced and of course we had to
have we couldn't move we didn't have one
cent of US government money in this
operation never and we couldn't move
without cash in advance because the
whole process was stalled without money
because the CIA had to have money in
advance they would not float this with
their money the Defense Department had
to have money in advance and so on just
before you get off that I take it what
you're saying is that until you had the
money from the Iranians put in lake
resources and out of that money paid to
the US government the price that it was
charging for the military hardware the
military hardware stayed in US
government stocks yes and and no moves
were made even preliminary moves could
be made until till the money was in the
system
getting back to Gore Vaughn afar I think
you forgot to tell so I was having an
acid conversation with mr. Gurbani
foreign that
telephone and I told him that I thought
that he had behaved very poorly that he
was old he was promising the moon always
and never never producing and that I was
going to recommend that he be terminated
now he misinterpreted that and he
companion I don't I don't mean that to
be funny he but he took it the wrong way
and and he told mr. near that I was
going to have him I was trying to have
him killed
and I think I even said later not a bad
idea but I it's not what I had in mind
from from this time onward I was
complaining and so were my colleagues
about the givanni fire connection it
seemed to me to be too fraught with
problems there was a a just a big
operational security problem and it was
a very inefficient connection in a very
indefinite connection nonetheless to see
Court will return to that but let's get
back to the transaction that was being
negotiated I take it you learned shortly
after the 6th of February that an
agreement had been made yes right and
the agreement was that the Iranians
would meet face to face with US
government officials in Europe and that
they would do so after 500 toes were
delivered and the first transaction was
to involve a thousand toes so the plan
was to deliver 500 toes as a sign of our
willingness and good faith and then to
have the meeting in Europe and then if
the meeting were judged to be a
successful meeting to deliver the
balance of the first thousand toes
another five hundred now so this may
take it to me in Europe was not simply a
meeting with gorban afar but was a
meeting with some other people yes I'd
like to discuss that now if it's the
right time it's not quite the right time
yet but I take it that these were
Iranian government officials said is
correct what was agreed to about on the
subject of
hostages if anything there was no
agreement on hostages for this
transaction the subject of hostages was
one of the agenda items to be taken up
at the London at the European meeting
what was the price for the toes the
price we charged for the toes was ten
million dollars for one thousand toes
and gore bunny far
finally deposited that amount of money
to the lake resources account and then
out of that money you pay the US
government yes and how did you do that
we transferred the money to the US
government to an account that the agency
gave us in Switzerland
before getting into the meeting in
Frankfurt I take it that the toes were
in fact shipped after the money had been
received into lake resources account and
the government paid yes we started
moving the toes out of the out of Texas
on the 19th of February in 1986 did you
move them all at the same time yes we
moved all thousand toes on to southern
air transport 707 aircraft to Israel and
then beginning I think about the 22nd or
so of February we transferred the first
500 toes to Tehran how was that done and
this was done in a in a secret way via
an Israeli 707 aircraft which had been
sterilized that is all markings removed
from it and it was chartered by me I
agreed to pay the Israeli government a
price for the use of the airplane and I
had to furnish the crew and where did
the crew come from and the crew came
from a southern air transport they were
we actually had two crews that were used
they were specially selected from from
their pilots and and they were screened
by me and if there are any heroes in
this story it's got to be them they they
were tremendous they were fantastic they
were professional and they pulled it off
beautifully how did they actually go
they winter and by a route that I had
devised so as to keep them out of any
other country's airspace it turned out
that with the loads that we were
carrying we could just barely fly a very
long route down the Red Sea in
international airspace
around the southern end of the Saudi
Arabian Peninsula and then up into the
Sea of Oman and coast into Iran just
east of the port of Bandar Abbas we
computed that with with good weather we
could make it safely pretty safely to to
Bhandar Abbas of course planning a route
like this on paper and actually flying
it too sometimes
two different things your your fuel
flows specifics have to be proved but we
were fairly confident that we could do
it safely and we also devised a a covert
command control communication system
whereby I could control these missions
from my from my command post in Israel
and is that where you were during these
flights
yes there have been a lot of reports
even this morning in the news that I
that I flew to Tehran
I'd never went to Tehran I did not fly
to Tehran did this first shipment of 500
toes down the Red Sea and into Iran go
smoothly yes it went very smoothly the
weather was not bad and they landed at
the airfield in bandar abbas on the
southern coast of iran and discharged
the the 500 tows offloaded them there
and then flew empty to Tehran where they
unloaded there were two they were
supposed to unload the 18 Hawks that
were had been sitting there all this
time there were only 17 Hawks provided
to them they claimed that they had torn
down the 18th when looking for something
special of course there was nothing
special
and therefore they only returned 17
Hawks it took almost 12 hours to load
those 17 Hawks into the aircraft and I
was in quite a sweat because I was out
of contact with them a lot longer than I
thought should have been the case
but finally they came up on the on the
air as they departed Iranian airspace
and influentially back to to Tel Aviv
and lifted quite a load from my
shoulders
absolutely so that was uneventful series
of flights and did the meeting with the
Iranian officials then take place a few
days thereafter yes sir if the meeting
started I think on the 24th or 25th of
February and we're in in the city of
Frankfurt Germany at the airport hotel
who was there and present in this
meeting I flew up from Israel to join
the meeting president in the meeting
were all over north hitting the US
delegation the chief of the Near East
section of the Central Intelligence
Agency was a member of his delegation
also present was my partner mr. Albert
Hakeem and this is tell us how he's I'd
still rarely he didn't want to be there
he protested about being pressed into
service there but he served as our
translator interpreter the agency had
very few people who were proficient in
Farsi language they apparently had one
lady who was pretty good but we couldn't
use a woman in this role with the
Iranians and they just couldn't come up
with anyone to to fill the bill so we
pressed him into service and I made a
slight mistake I notified mr. near of
his mr. Hakeem's name as being the US
candidate for us being the US translator
and he passed this to korban fr who
took extreme exception he said that mr.
Hakim was an enemy of the state this was
crazy he knew this name and so on and so
so I violated one of my own rules I
should have used alias for him and this
covert up and I didn't so that for a
while I thought that Hakim could not
fulfill this role because of Corbin FRS
objections but the agency was still
unable to come up with a Farsi
translator and I'm not near nearly good
enough from Farsi to fill that role and
we could not rely on mr. Gurbani fire to
be our translator so in the in the last
days before the meeting occurred I
simply told Alberti he had to do the job
and so we disguised him and we now we
mr. Hakim has his hairs a little sparse
on top and we bought a wig for him grain
and gray wig and put glasses on him and
amazingly he looked like a totally
different man it was just amazing even I
couldn't recognize him and he filled
that role in the meeting what name did
he use he used the name Ibrahim Ibrahim
a Turkish of Turkish descent who was a
contract translator here for the
government and flew West mr. near at the
meeting mr. near was at the meeting and
of course korban afar knew near knew who
he was but mr. near was under US cover
at the meeting will you explain that
under US cover we passed him off as as
an American official for the purposes of
that meeting the by the way where what
name were you using and what name was
mr. North using North used the name of
mr. good and at this at this meeting
I used the the name of
general Adams now the reason why that
was necessary was that they wanted me to
present that is north and the agency
wanted me to present part of the
intelligence briefing which was to be
given at this meeting it had been agreed
that some representative sample of
tactical intelligence information would
be briefed to the Iranian delegation and
since it involved a lot of military
symbology and order of battle jargon and
since I pretty familiar with the
Iranians they asked me if I would fill
that role so I did who was there from
the Iranian side an official and
official from the office of the prime
minister of Iran and he had with him an
aide and and two kernels that he
introduced his being from their military
intelligence organization we believed
however that one of the kernels actually
was from the office of the Prime
Minister and mr. gorban afar and and mr.
Gulen Authority is and you just very
briefly described the meeting yes the
the main meeting which took place I was
not present it was a meeting among the
representatives from Iran along with
Gore Bani far Oliver North
the CIA official and of course Hakim
acting his translator these meetings
were taped surreptitiously
I was briefed later as to what had
transpired and my understanding was that
North went through his talking points
which he had an officially blessed set
of talking points they went through the
u.s. strategic objectives the u.s.
concerns about the Soviet threat in the
region the u.s. is concerned about the
continuing iran-iraq war and our desire
to see an honorable ending to that what
is honorable ending mean with honorable
ending means that you know you can face
your people with the with the with the
solution that you devised but The
Killing has to stop it's destabilizing
and so on this was the the u.s. position
the matter of hostages did come up in
this in this meeting as it always did
but the as the tapes would prove the
strategic nature this initiative
occupied most of the discussion there
was not a discussion about swapping arms
for hostages and indeed there were no
hostages released nor were any expected
to be released as as a part of this
February deal you feel certain of that
that there were no hostages expected to
be released I didn't expect any to be
released I was not informed that there
was any plan for any to be released as a
result of this initial deal in any event
that you are not told that any work to
be released and none work and none were
and we didn't and we didn't plan for any
to be released what was if anything what
was agreed on for the future the US
delegation was pleased with the meeting
it was agreed in this meeting that there
would be a future high-level meeting
between the and in the near future
between high-level officials of the
United States and high-ranking members
of the Iranian government and they were
talking in terms of Foreign Ministries
and State Department high officials
would it be fair to say mr. seacord that
a lot was made at this meeting out of
the fact that officials of the two
governments were meeting face to face
for the first time in a long time yes
that was that was also a big point when
the meeting was summed up at the end
that this was the first time that there
had been face-to-face discussions
between Iranian and US officials since
1981 there was agreed that this future
meeting would take place on Kish Island
which is a small island south on the
south coast of Iran did you have a
reaction to that as a location yes I was
very pleased when I when I learned that
quiche was to be the site I was very
pleased with that because I felt that
our delegation would be secure there we
have strong forces in the region and
although I thought that our friends in
Iran were probably going to deal with us
in good faith one couldn't be too sure
and I was of course conditioned by my
previous service in trying to release
the hostages from Iran in 1980 so I was
concerned about the safety of our
delegation Kish was a great place I
thought was a a meeting actually agreed
upon or a specific meeting agreed upon
or was it agreed simply to discuss it
further in the future no it was agreed
that there would be a meeting but there
were no specifics there was no date set
and the attendees were not named it was
agreed that would be done as soon as
possible but in the near future you
mentioned some intelligence without
getting into the details of its nature
can you tell us what was said and done
on the subject of intelligence
information yes this briefing was
presented to the two Colonels this is a
briefing by whom it was a briefing by me
and
the chief of Near East section of CIA
the briefing consisted of a small
section of the iran-iraq border in which
details of order of battle were
described and there was one
high-altitude photograph that was
annotated that was showed to them but
not given to them so this was an example
that the purpose of the briefing was to
show the type of information that the
United States is capable of providing if
they have an intelligence exchange
agreement following the meeting was the
second group of 500 tow missiles
actually shipped yes the meeting was
judged to be successful and I was asked
to deliver the second set of 500 tows
and placed a call to my crew and who
were waiting in Israel and they
delivered the second 500 toast this time
to Teheran uneventfully we learned that
we could fly a little farther than we
had originally calculated so the toes
were already in Tel Aviv as after the
meeting they were simply shipped on yes
sir
have you based on your review of the
records made available to the committee
by Hakim computed the cost price
received and expenses related to the
thousand toes that were sold to Iran in
February yes I have could you tell us
how much was paid for them into the lake
resources account yes ten million
dollars was paid into the lake resources
account how much was paid to the United
States government out of the lake
resources account the US government was
paid three point seven million dollars
for the tows that leaves a difference of
six point three million dollars yes and
what were the expenses associated with
that transaction
there were expenses of eight hundred and
fifty thousand dollars that were paid
there were two million dollars set aside
for self insurance Israel demanded that
these aircraft be insured for a Hall
value of two million dollars each so if
we used one airplane we had to have two
million set aside if we use two we had
f4 these are the Israeli sanitized
airplanes that you were using but
Israeli transport from Tel Aviv to
Teheran
yes you may you may recall that the
reason why the Schwimmer plan broke down
was because he couldn't locate any
aircraft and that and the insurance
problem was the reason so our solution
to the insurance problem was to set
aside two million dollars in this case
additionally an amount which was later
defined but not defined then had to be
fenced or set aside to purchase Israeli
tows remember I said that we would have
to purchase after the delivery of four
thousand tows we had
to purchase in another 500 for Israel
later that figure was determined to be
eight hundred and twenty two thousand so
that was set aside thus if you do the
arithmetic you'll see that we had
approximately 2.6 million dollars
surplus in our accounts at the end of
this transaction plus a 2 million dollar
certificate of deposit even I take it
once the Israeli airplane had returned
back safely at least for the time being
that 2 million dollars was available to
you it was it certainly was available
but we never took it out of the CDs for
the entire period of the operation
because we were always looking forward
to the next the next cycle after this
transaction did you have any discussions
with Oliver North about how to use this
2.6 million dollar surplus yes would you
destroy Colonel Norris position was
consistent throughout in February and
later he wanted me to use all available
surpluses to support the contra project
did you have a number of I was I was
comfortable with that I had a number of
conversations with him about this matter
over a period of time there was always a
certain amount of tension on this on
this subject because North wasn't
running this operation
I was along with Hakim and of course he
wasn't sitting around worrying about
having enough money to execute it
because we couldn't couldn't be in a
position of being forced to go back to
go Bonnie far for money if we had an
overrun I mean that would have been
ridiculous we could never get away with
that we had to keep sufficient revenues
in these accounts to stay fluid so that
we could go on to the next operation and
remember not one dime of US money went
into this operation so we had to be very
very careful on this and so I was
perfectly willing to send funds to the
contract from these surpluses and as the
bank records which you've got from mr.
Hakim show we did
but never was I able to send as much as
as how I never thought we should
to see court was there were there
further discussions and negotiations
thereafter on the subject of the meeting
the meeting between high government
officials if he just yes there were and
without getting into each individual
discussion how did those discussions
develop well I think there were a lot of
discussions on by telephone amongst the
key players which were north and near
and gore Banach far and between Gurbani
far and his principles in Iran but there
was a very important meeting which took
place the 7th or 8th of March I was not
in the meeting but North the chief of
any CIA and a the CIA
retired officer who had been recalled
for this project mr. George cave and
gaura vani fire all met in Paris to
discuss the the upcoming meeting at Kish
at this meeting
korban afar informed them that he had
been informed that Kish was not
available this was no longer an
available option the meeting would have
to be in Tehran I learned of this of
course after they returned from the
meeting also for the first time
korban a fire raised the issue of
improved hawk spare parts not missiles
but spare parts as being materials that
were now wanted in this initiative and
that the toes were were less important
according to him now but they really one
of the spare parts for the top for the
Hawks at this meeting not in the core
Boni far as presence of course it was
also agreed that both sides the Israeli
side and the American side would
commence an active search for new
channels in communications with
with Iran the korban a fire channel was
obviously a flawed leaving that aside
for the moment I will we will return to
it later keeping on the subject of the
meeting was a meeting eventually agreed
on and arranged in Tarrant yes it
eventually was agreed to and it it took
place in May much later than expected
and who was the American official who
who attended that meeting mr. McFarlane
and mr. north
Colonel north and Jorge cave attended
this meeting along with another official
from the NSC staff Howard tiger was
there any advance trip in anticipation
of an in preparation for the meeting
that mr. McFarlane attended there was no
advance trip was there ever one
contemplated yes and what happened there
there it was strongly recommended by by
three of us near myself and in North
were all recommending that a preparatory
meeting take place there was after all
as far as I knew no agenda even agreed
to for this meeting and so it seemed to
me at least and I think to the others to
be not well organized and in fact I've
been to many many international meetings
and I don't think I've ever been to one
where there wasn't some preparatory work
done in advance however the position I
was taken that there would be no advance
preparatory meeting that the terms and
conditions that have been agreed to in
Frankfurt were sufficient and that the
would and that the Iranian side would
simply have to deal with that and so
there was no advance meeting and that
was a big mistake
Jassi court was this meeting in some way
tied to the Hawks spare parts that mr.
gorban afar had raised at the March
meeting yes it was and the plan that was
finally agreed to again working through
Gurbani fire the plan that was finally
agreed to was that the plane that the
McFarland delegation came in on would
carry a sample of these spare parts and
they did they carried one of the 13
pallets of I Hawk spare parts that were
involved and there was just a sample
let's back up a little bit mr. C Court
what can you tell us some more details
about the gore bond of our request to
purchase spare parts well he raised this
issue in this early March meeting and
then later in March forwarded through
near to us a listing of some 240 line
items of spare parts that they wanted
they provided the stock numbers from
their catalogs and and they were just a
hodgepodge of spare parts didn't make a
lot of sense to me
they included generators wire bundles
things like this things that I was
fairly sure they already had quite
frankly but in any case that was what
they wanted and so was this listing that
served as the guide to Agnetha for the
CIA to aggregate these parts were you
involved in discussions concerning the
price that you would charge or that the
US government would charge for these
spare parts yes I was and the
discussions went on over several month
period the delivery was not made until
late May but in March we were trying to
price these things the there was a lot
of confusion in this
they couldn't locate all the parts that
were wanted initially the prices changed
always upward the we couldn't even
determine what what the weight of these
parts were going to be for quite a long
while I didn't or the volume I didn't
even know how many aircraft it was going
to take initially who participated in
the discussions of the price that Gore
Bond afar would be charged for the hawk
spare parts besides you North
participated I think that one of his
assistants also listened to us talk
about it mister Colonel role and also I
discussed it with near on several
occasions well get into the details
later but I take it as fair to say that
the price that you eventually decided to
charge was substantially in excess of
the amount of money paid to the US
Treasury yes
did you a north talked about the reason
for this difference yes of course we did
and and there were there were a number
of reasons and the contra was one of
them contra the contra requirement was
much on our minds as I think some of the
Cale 43 messages showed you we were
running out of money to support the
Contras so that was on our minds but
additionally I had in my mind at that
time this great concern this great
uncertainty the prices were rising all
the time I was also informed during this
time frame that the earlier transaction
had been underpriced
by CIA and they had a two hundred and
forty thousand dollar overrun which had
to be pay I couldn't afford to have an
overrun so so that was in my mind in
April we had to buy a ship of course
that became a factor I didn't even know
how many airplanes were going to have to
use initially that was a factor I
discussed this with near I knew that
what I was going to have to use a
minimum of two aircraft because the
aircraft carrying the delegation had to
stay with the party in Tehran that
therefore then meant
had to set aside four million dollars
for insurance and this was an Israeli
demand so all these factors were
combined together and we finally priced
the the spare parts at fifteen million
dollars and that's what the core
Bonaparte put in when you say that's
what Gore Bonaparte put in that means
put into lake resources I take record
and that price was agreed by you and
north and that's the price given to Gore
bono far that is correct
who actually gave it to Gore Bono farm
I'm not sure yet but it appears that he
had a financier no I'm sorry who told
him the price Oh near and who told near
the price I did
now I think you indicated that one
pallet of these spare parts went with
mr. McFarlane to Turan yes
was that pursuant to an agreement with
the Iranians that's what I was told and
what happened to the rest of the spare
parts where were they they were stored
in Israel for later delivery after the
Tehran meeting so all of the spare parts
after korban afar put his money into the
lake resources account all of the spare
parts were transported first to Tel Aviv
is that correct yes and is that by
transport planes and you paid for the
transportation I paid for it and then
all but one pallet were left in Tel Aviv
and the one pallet went in the plane
with mr. McFarlane and his group I take
it to Turan that is correct
where were you at the time I was in my
command post in Tel Aviv prior to mr.
McFarland's trip had there been prior to
the time his plane actually took off had
there been discussions on the subject of
hostages
well there were a lot of discussions I
told you that the hostages were
discussed at the Frankfurt meeting
hostages were discussed with near and
with korban fr frequently by North End
by me but as far as I know and this will
surprise some people I guess but as far
as I know there was no Iranian agreement
to produce all the hostages at the time
of the meeting in Teheran I know that
this expectation arose somehow I don't
know how exactly that expectation got
into McFarland's head I can
have to ask him I don't know but I know
of no such agreement I was surprised to
learn that that was one of the
negotiating points one of the sticking
points and I take it you had been in
frequent contact with mr. north and mr.
near in the weeks and days preceding the
trip yes now we had an expectation that
we might be able to convince the
Iranians to exercise their influence at
the time of the meeting they were surely
thereafter to gain the release of the
hostages but I knew of no plan for a
simultaneous release of the hostages
simultaneous with the meeting what do
you know mr. seacord about what actually
occurred in Teheran
well what I've what I've read in a tower
report and what I was debriefed on by
the several of the participants when
they returned to Israel I was in
communications with the delegation by a
special communication system but I was
not privy to their conversations with
Washington so I had to rely on
debriefing when they returned for my
information were you actually asked to
do something while you were in Tel Aviv
and they were in Tehran two things tell
us both one was to prepare to be ready
to deliver the other 12 pallets of of I
Hawk spare parts and I had a second
airplane set up for that and I was
actually told to launch it
I think the 27th of May and we did
launch it under positive control and
then after about four hours I was told
to reorder the plane to return to base
and I did did just that so the plane
containing the the rest of the Hawks
bare parts actually took off started in
flight towards Teheran and you were
instructed while it was in the air to
have it returned that is correct and
that would that was part of the plan
this was not an offhand thing we had
anticipated doing
something like this secondly I had been
asked by North some time as just before
this this mission to support the DEA
people in a another attempt to locate
and perhaps rescue some of the hostages
in Lebanon they were working out of
Cyprus and they picked up some money
which I asked mr. Hakim to arrange to
support their expenses they actually
picked it up in themselves in Geneva and
this little operation was going on at
the same time it was a little bit
confusing for me and and in fact after I
heard of some curious things about this
Cyprus operation one of which was they
wanted my my boat my ship to go down and
stand offshore to be used in some
operation to pick up the hostages I've
got in touch with mr. Tom Klein's and
and dispatched him to Cyprus to join up
with the DEA agents and try to find out
what was going on I have a lot of faith
and clients his ability as an
intelligence officer and his operational
judgment so he did go there he assessed
the operation and notified me that he
gave it no more initially said 40%
chance then later a 20% chance of
success and that did not succeed so
those were the two things I was asked to
do what was the final outcome of this
meeting the Teheran meeting failed it
stuck on the issue of the failure of the
Iranians to arrange for the release of
the American hostages in the McFarland
mission broke off after some some
discussions with high-ranking members of
the government they did go through some
discussions there they did present
points they went down that road
after a few days and the hostages were
not released they aborted the mission
return did they return to Tel Aviv they
returned to Tel Aviv and then
immediately the bulk of the party
traveled onward to Washington did you
have any brief conversations with mr.
McFarlane and his party before they
traveled on yes I had a brief
conversation with the MacFarlane himself
he was very disappointed and of course
so were we all and also had a brief
conversation with Oliver North but they
were in a hurry to get on home how about
mr. near mr. near I talked with a lot
he was bitterly disappointed at the at
the outcome he felt that that hadn't
been handled correctly he felt that
should have stayed longer thought they
were making progress thought that the
the Iranians it was that was fair to
give the Iranians more time because the
Iranians were disorganized at Gore
bonfires preparations had been
inadequate and so on mr. seacord
simultaneous with the Hawks spare part
transaction was there a transaction
involving toes yes and did this relate
to the 508 toes or however many toes it
was that the Israelis had claimed they
had been promised replenishment for yes
the Israelis we're demanding their toes
back time had gone on and they were
unhappy so it was decided that we would
take the 820 mm that had been set aside
and the Israelis would add whatever was
required to that sum to procure the 508
toes and we shipped them to Tel Aviv at
the same time as in a separate airplane
but at the same time as we shipped the
Hawks pairs was that all also in a
southern air transport yes you paid the
expenses I paid it and how much
additional money did the Israelis
contribute at that time
to the purchase price of the 508 toes
they contributed what amounted to 1.4
million dollars and you added that to
the 822 that you would set aside and
pass that to the US Treasury and read
that yes paid that to the US Treasury
now not that's not correct I paid it too
I'm sorry I didn't pay the US Treasury I
paid it to the CIA account and to your
knowledge it went from the air into the
US Treasury eventually I think I went to
the Pentagon
mr. seacord in May when mr. McFarlane
returned from Teheran I take it lake
resources has been paid fifteen million
dollars for the hawk spare parts almost
all of the hawk spare parts remain in
tel-aviv the hostages have not been
released
what is the status of the arrangement
involving the hawk spare parts and the
hostages at that time well we were in it
back in limbo again we were from my
point of view in a state of considerable
confusion because we had been ordered
not to deliver the balance of the spare
parts so they stayed in Israel who
ordered you not to do that of McFarlane
and north now the spare parts had been
paid for they had been paid for and this
was a source of a little bit of concern
because korban a fire and the Iranians
were demanding that that their goods be
delivered they paid for them they want
them delivered well why were you ordered
not to deliver them if they have been
paid because
it was judged that the Iranians had not
acted in good faith and that the meeting
had been a failure therefore then they
didn't want to continue the initiative
the initiative was being reviewed with
consideration being given to cancelling
it well what was it that the Iranians
had not done they had not simultaneously
released the American hostages and
therefore it was decided that the that
the spare parts would not be delivered
now I want to stay with this transaction
just for a moment was that issue
eventually resolved it was but it took a
long time how was it eventually resolved
gore Boni fire eventually resolved it
through discussions and meetings with
NIR and with north and also I believe
with the CIA representative and it
resolved eventually an agreement to
deliver the balance of the spare parts
after one hostage was released in the
one hostage was released in late July
and the parts were finally delivered
then in early August these are the bulks
of the I Hawk spare parts that weld the
12 pallets yes that had been delivered
to Tel Aviv in May yeah that's correct
they were delivered after the hostage
had been released that's correct but I'm
up until that time we were in some
financial jeopardy as you can imagine we
might have had to return a great deal of
money I take it a certain amount of that
money had been spent on the Contras yes
now back to the money
did an issue arise relating to a price
list
sometime after McFarland's visit to
television this this further complicated
our lives after the Tehran mission
because the Iranians were complaining to
go by fire not only that their goods had
not been delivered but they claimed to
have a price listing which showed that
the prices that they had the price they
had been charged was greatly inflated
and unfair that this this was bringing a
lot of pressure down Gore Bonnie fires
ahead and so eventually we got this
listing which they called a microfiche
listing it turned out to be a valid
listing but it was a cost of manufacture
listing which is the my understanding of
it was that it was a list of prices that
the prime contractor could expect from
various vendors
and so it did not really relate to the
price that even the Pentagon pays it was
not a valid list but nonetheless they
raised a good deal of turbulence over
this matter I take it that the list
showed that the price for these Hawks
spare parts was considerably lower than
the price that they had actually paid
that's right and but it was not a valid
list of valid lists of the actual prices
but the fact of the matter is the price
charge was considerably higher than a
true price list would have shown yes and
the the price list did you ever see it I
don't recall ever seeing it it was
described to me but I don't recall ever
seeing it do you know whether it was
sent to US government officials it was
yes it was it was sent to North office
during this same period of time did you
learn anything that that gave you
concern about your ability to keep this
project secret yes it seemed like
everything bad was happening in this in
this time frame I learned after the
Tehran meeting that guarana fire claimed
that he was dealing with financiers and
he named Saudi had non khashoggi as
being one of these financiers and that
he and that he was not dealing with
Iranian money
he was bridging with the borrowed money
and had been doing so all along the
apparently the Israelis knew this I did
not know it I take it the point here is
mr. seacord that he is borrowed money to
put into lake resources and he can't
repay that money until the goods are
shipped to Iran and Iran pays him this
was his claim and he claimed that he
borrowed from mr. khashoggi and someone
else well first it was Justice yogya
that I learned over then I learned that
there were two Canadian business men
behind khashoggi or at least this was
another claim I'm not sure that that was
true but this was the information we
were receiving and that
this was a matter of additional concern
yet and then finally we were told that
these people were going to go public
maybe even sue they in fact did through
an intermediary contact the director of
CIA about this problem and so it was
unraveling I take it the problem was
that he had deposited fifteen million
dollars in lake resources and because
the hawk spare parts had not been
shipped he was unable to repay the
financiers that's correct now and and
they were putting pressure on him and he
was complaining to various people mr.
near mr. north among them that's right
and was that problem resolved when the
hawk spare parts were finally shipped I
don't think the problem was ever
resolved well isn't it a fact that it
was not resolved because you learned
that mr. gorban FR said given the price
list iran was unwilling to pay the full
fifteen million dollars this was his
story but we were never able to confirm
this story and the CIA people had
serious reservations about that claim
but that was his claim that was his
claim and he was claiming therefore that
even after the hawk spare parts had been
shipped but he was unable to repay his
fin and Sears and that they were putting
increasing pressure on him to do so that
is what he said and then I take it you
learn from a different source that these
financiers were in fact complaining that
they had not been paid yes I learned
from from North that they and then later
from George cave that they had
approached the director CIA and then two
CIA employees met with the intermediary
and approximately when was that I don't
have that date but I think it was
probably in August or September could it
have been as late as October sure could
have been
it was mint it was it was toward the end
of this saga and was it at that point of
time that you learned that they were
threatening to sue no that was brought
up earlier that korban a fire go bonfire
had mentioned this too near who had
mentioned it to north and I in any event
at some point in time you learned they
were threatening to sue yes did you did
you learn that they had threatened to
reveal the fact that some of the
proceeds of this money had gone to the
Contras and that's why they hadn't been
repaid I I don't recall that arising at
the time but later I heard you know of
course that they that they had said this
but I don't recall being brought to my
attention at the time have you by
reviewing the committee's records
relating to these Swiss bank accounts
lake resources and others made a
computation of the surplus on the hawk
spare parts transaction that you've just
been testifying about yeah we've made an
approximate computation and all right
let's start with the money received into
the lake resources bank account recall
that we had to procure 508 toes as well
as the Hawks so the total money in was
about sixteen and a half million that's
15 from gorbunov are in the hounds from
Israel million and a half from Israel
approximately yes approximately and how
much to the six point five of that was
paid immediately to a CIA account we've
computed from those records of mr. Hakim
that about that's leaving a difference
of approximately ten million yes and
then the expenses for the various
transportation
and related activities we computer to be
about 1.7 million
that leaves 8.3 yes and then we as I
said reserved actually put in a
certificate deposit and another
additional two million for Hall
insurance which leaves six point five of
surplus at that time plus four million
dollars in certificates of deposit for
insurance now why did you have to add
two million dollars self insurance at
that time because we had to use two
airplanes instead of one and you would
already set aside two million from the
earlier transaction so there was an
additional requirement of one one
further amount equal to two million
that's correct
so may I suggest that we stop the
interrogation at this point the hearing
will stand in recess until two o'clock
this afternoon
the hearing will please come to order
mr. Neil's please proceed Thank You mr.
chairman it's a secret just to make
certain that the record is clear on this
point you testified in connection with
the Hawks spare part transaction that
the amount of money paid to the CIA
account was six point five million I
take it that includes both the Hulk's
spare parts and the 508 tows sent to
Israel that's correct
and you had received both from monies
that you had set aside from an earlier
transaction and from an additional
amount that the Israelis had had given
you you had received about 2.2 million
dollars or allocated that amount of
money for those toes that is correct
I'd like you to turn to documents which
have been collectively marked exhibit
five
okay you have those in front of you
yesterday and are these your notes they
are were they made contemporaneously
with the transactions that are are noted
yes in other words these are not notes
that you've made recently these were
made at the time that is correct
looking at the first page I take it
these are notes relating to monies
coming in and money's going out of the
Swiss bank accounts that you've been
testifying about plus planning notes and
when it says all accounts at the top of
the first page that refers to the Swiss
accounts yes it does at the very top of
the page it says balance 7th February
1986 87,000 was that an exact amount or
is that a an estimate you made at the
time it was an estimate that I was given
at the time by mr. Hakim and underneath
that it says deposits 10 February 19
February 18 February 5 M refers to five
million dollars yes and are the two five
M figures the money paid by mr. Gravano
far for the thousand toes that were
shipped to Iran at about that time yes
and the 1 million is a contribution
that's correct
and underneath it are those expenses
that were paid out of this these monies
yes and are a number of the expenses on
that list expenses for the benefit of
the Contras yes like you to turn the
page to the second page of this exhibit
down at the bottom of the page there are
some numbers with a line drawn through
them are those anticipated disbursements
which may or may not actually
made yes it was the planning this is
planning data and the the entries that
don't have lines drawn through them
those are actual disbursements had taken
yes
I'd like you to flip the three pages
forward it appears to say at the top of
the page continuation sheet number three
do you have that in front of you
continuation sheet number two the might
the top has gone from mine turn at one
page pass continuation sheet number two
okay do you have that yes you yes down
at the bottom it says deposits 514 516
516 do you see those numbers yes there's
a deposit of 10 million dollars is that
correct yes and five million dollars yes
is that payment for the hawk spare parts
yes
and then there's a figure one point four
six million is that the amount of money
that the Israelis put into the account
for the toes yes and then below it
there's a figure eight hundred and
twenty-two thousand yes is that the
amount of money that you would set aside
from the earlier receipts which are
allocated to purchase of the toes
correct and that together with a one
point four six million is the amount of
money that you actually use to purchase
the toes yes I'd like you to turn to the
last page of this exhibit
you have that in front of you yes
very last page I have it just the very
last page of the exhibit have a list of
receipts and disbursements for an
earlier time period okay that's the next
the last page in my file
okay I'm sorry next to the last page are
those receipts and disbursements for an
earlier time period yes they are set
1985 yes sir and there's this money in
and out of the Swiss bank accounts that
you've been testifying about yes
direct your attention to an entry 5
October 3k good yes who what is good
mean Colonel north and what is 3k mean
$3,000 and does that mean $3,000 was
delivered to mr. good to mr. north yes
was that cash yes and what was the
purpose that was for I believe that was
for a DEA expense and it's the same true
of the 15 October entry down below that
says 5k good yes and it's the same true
of the entry 28 October 3k good yes mr.
Chairman I request that exhibit number 5
be made a part of the record at these
hearings
so see Court you've testified to a
certain dissatisfaction with mr. gorban
afar as an intermediary in the
relationship between US government and
the Iranian government did you make some
efforts in the summer of 1986 to find a
second channel as it were to the Iranian
government
yes working with mr. Hakim and that was
a channel that bypassed mr. Gribbon afar
yes
was this your idea it was an idea that
I'd had for a long time and it was my
idea was yours not you weren't asked to
do this by any government official no
but the government knew what I was doing
who when the government knew what you
were doing Colonel North knew that I was
looking and so did the CIA and did mr.
Hakim talked to some of his old contacts
from the days in which he lived in Iran
yes and eventually was a a meeting set
up in August in Brussels between you and
mr. Hakim and a relative of a high
official of the Iranian government yes
sir and did you pursue at that time the
possibility of a long term relationship
between the United States and Iran yes
and at the end of the conversation did
you mention weapons and hostages yes was
there then at that meeting were there
any officials of the US government
president no only Hakim and I was a
later meeting set up in in in this
country at which government officials
were present yes in September and was
that in the old executive office
building yes and was mr. North present
he was in charge of the meeting again
was and a representative from the CIA
yes and the same relative of a high
Iranian official yes along with two
assistants and did you again have
discussions about a long term
relationship between the two governments
and at the end of the discussions bring
up the subjects of arms and hostages
yeah well well North did this and
conducted the discussion as I was a
note-taker
and and have I accurately characterized
the discussions indeed and was there a
third meeting in October in Frankfurt at
which this relative of the high Iranian
official was present together with you
and mr. North and CIA official yes and
did you once again discuss a long-term
relationship between the two countries
and also discuss arms and hostages yes
and at mr. North leave that meeting
before any agreement had been reached
yes did you pursue the conversations
then did you then lead the the
conversations after mr. North left with
mr. with Colonel North authorization yes
and did you eventually agree on a
nine-point plan part of which was that
the US government would ship 500 tows to
Iran and the Iranians would would and
obtain the release of at least one
hostage yes I managed to get them to
adopt with minor changes North's
seven-point plan was then referred to as
a nine-point plan and was agreed to by
them and by me a draft that means a
subject to approval by a higher
authority and did you obtain that
approval I sent it back to the White
House by a KL 43 and it was subsequently
approved
and did the sale eventually occur it did
and how much money was paid by the
Iranians for the toes three point six
million dollars and how much my I take
it that was into one of your Swiss
accounts yes and how much money was paid
out of the Swiss accounts to the CIA
account just over two million dollars
and what were the approximate expenses
about two hundred and twenty thousand
and what was the total surplus from that
transaction approximately 1.3 million
dollars now if you take the three
transactions that were handled through
your Swiss accounts the first one of a
thousand tows the second of the hawk
spare parts and the third of the five
hundred toes what is the combined
surplus from the three transactions when
you do that arithmetic you arrive at a
number of fourteen million dollars and
does that include the four million
dollars that you have previously said
was at least was set aside for insurance
purposes
yes were these tow missiles shipped to
Iran approximately October 30th of last
year yes now exactly what toes were they
that were shipped on that day these toes
were the toes that had been stored in in
Israel since the preceding May since May
of 86 was that the toes that that we
shipped to Israel in in May that
represented the promise to replenish
that had been made the previous year yes
but they rejected them dude
their age and is that the reason those
toes went on to Iran yes and did we
subsequently deliver some newer toes to
Israel yes a few days later after the 30
October delivery sometime in early
November yes and was a hostage released
at approximately the time of these
shipments yes just after the shipment
was delivered and were you involved in
in that aspect of the operation yes I
was involved in the north and I traveled
to Beirut for three hours
arriving there at midnight one night and
we spent three hours with embassy
personnel briefing them on the
intelligence we had been given with
respect to the upcoming release we
wanted them to have every possible
chance of rescuing the hostage safely
and so we were able to convey
directly to the people who were
responsible for going into West Beirut
after they were notified in picking up
the hostage mr. Jacobson worked well did
you continue to pursue this second
channel thereafter yes and I take it you
regarded it as promising I did and so
did CIA and so did northen the Jew
indeed even continued to pursue this
this channel after the time when there
were news reports of the sale of arms to
Iran we tried now I take it that this
second channel bypassed mr. gorban afar
in effect yes yes we asked them to
provide other business for mr. Grove on
a fire however in an attempt to soften
the blow I take it you were concerned
about you knew that mr. Grove Onofre was
not going to like being bypassed I take
it that's correct
that's
and I take it you were concerned about
what might happen if mr. gorban afar
became too dissatisfied we were
completely concerned about security
security means what leaks that he would
revelations that he would make this
whole operation public if he was left
out that was a concern yes and so you
asked the people in the second channel
to do something which would make him
happy I did make that request and did
you hear back whether that worked
they agreed but it the arrangements
didn't get in place fast enough and
there was eventually a leak as you put
it yes and the as we all know this
matter became public right after it
became public I take it there was
eventually a presidential press
conference there was a speech and a
press conference during the week of the
press conference which is the week
beginning November 17th did you have any
contacts with people in the White House
on the general subject of what should be
said about the Iranian initiative well
before before the presidential speech I
took the position that the president
should make a firm speech which clearly
laid out what the objectives were and
some of the operational details and to
make no bones about it that it was his
operation that he was responsible for it
had directed it endorsed it tried we
failed we're going to try again that was
the line that I recommended they take
and in fact I drafted it I was so
concerned about how I actually drafted a
speech maybe a bit presumptuous of me
and I sent it to them to Admiral
Poindexter through North on the KL 43
the hard line was the line was thought
to be too hard however
how did you learn that I was informed of
that by huh by Colonel North all right
what else did you do on this subject or
what else happened well did there come a
time when you were asked to go to
Colonel Norris office in the old
executive office building during that
week you're talking about the week of
November 17 well yes indeed the speech
of course took place before that week
but I was called and asked to go to his
office on the I believe was the 18th of
November to help them the staff and they
had several staff members working
compile a chronology for the use of the
Director of Central Intelligence in his
upcoming testimony to the House and
Senate intelligence committees this I
believe was on Tuesday and I think that
the directors testimony was scheduled
for Friday and so I did help they were
trying to reconstruct events they were
trying to put together a chronology
working with several different papers
and there were a number of people
involved in the in the drafting exercise
and I helped did you and I take it you
you you read them yes yes did you I take
it your testimony as you did that on a
Tuesday did you return some time later
on in the week yes I was asked again on
Wednesday to come back because the work
was continuing and they weren't her a
great deal of time pressure because the
directors hearing was close at hand and
they did not have all the chronologies
of didn't have the chronology quite
right yet didn't have it quite well put
together I came down on on Wednesday as
requested I think it was in the morning
and looked at a new version will you
describe what happened when you looked
at the new version first perhaps you
should tell us who was present present I
think the same people were present both
days I
be off a little bit on that but I think
that there was the same group each day
there was Colonel North his assistant
Bob Burrell
mr. Howard tae sure of the NSC staff was
assisting and mr. George cave of Central
Intelligence was also assistant would
you describe what what happened on the
second day when you sat down to read the
draft chronology I read a few pages into
it and came to a part that had been
changed significantly and I questioned
it what was the change and what did she
say but the change had to do with
whether or not the president had
approved or acquiesced in the sale of
the the transfer of the Israeli arms in
1985 and the version on Tuesday which I
had helped out on laid out the facts as
I understood them which were which were
that the president had acquiesced in in
this in these transfers but on the
version which I read on Wednesday this
had been changed to indicate that the
president had not approved which was not
consistent with my understanding of the
facts however I was informed by Colonel
North that what what did you say to him
tell us exactly what you said to him and
then exactly what was said to you well I
stopped when I came to the relevant
portion of the text and I said to
Colonel North there's something wrong
here this is expletive deleted and he I
think he was expecting me to stop at
that point because he was he was ready
for my question and he said that mr.
McFarlane had drafted that section
himself he had done the night before
after I had seen the earlier draft and I
said well it's not you know not my
understanding of the facts they said
well that McFarland had drafted it
himself
meaning that the crown was the principal
he should know and I said fine thank you
very much I'll get out of you guys hair
see you later and I left I'd like you to
turn to exhibit number seven okay there
are a number of documents together
marked exhibit seven the one I would
like you to look at has eleven twenty
eighty six okay 2000 historical
chronology written on it I have it I'd
like you to turn to page five and at the
bottom of the first full paragraph it
says McFarland elevated the question to
the President and to the secretaries of
state and defense and the Director of
Central Intelligence the President
stated that while he could envision
providing material material support to
moderate elements in Iran if all the
Western hostages were freed he could not
approve any transfer of military
material at that time now I take it you
can't tell us for sure whether this is
the piece of paper that you read but my
question is is that the sum and
substance of the information that was
written on the document that you've just
testified about yes
now I would like you to turn to a
document which is dated 11 1786 mm
maximum version I'd like you to turn to
page 4 of that document and it says in
the middle of the third paragraph or
rather at the beginning of the third
paragraph on August 22 1985 the US
through the US citizen intermediary
acquiesced in an Israeli delivery of
military supplies 508 toes to Tehran and
at the end of the paragraph that says US
acquiescence in this Israeli Act
operation was based on a decision at the
highest level now again without asking
you whether this is the very document
that you reviewed at your first trip
down to the old executive office
building is that the information in
essence that was in the first draft you
looked at yes now I'd like you to turn
back to the document date at 11:20 86 mm
historical chronology
and I'd like you to turn to page six of
that document have you read page six of
that document recently yes only recently
and would it be fair to say that when
you were down in the old executive
office building of the week of November
17th reading you stopped at page five
that's correct as soon as you got to the
part where it said that the president
had not approved you stop reading
questioned mr. north and then left
that's accurate
now the second full paragraph on page
six relates to the mid-november
transaction involving the hawk missiles
is that correct yes is that paragraph
and the following one accurate no not in
my opinion in the middle of the second
paragraph it says with respect to that
transaction we I take it that refers to
the US government
we're assured at the time that the
Israelis were going to quote try oil
drilling parts as an incentive since we
had expressed so much displeasure over
the earlier toast shipment it's not
consistent with the facts as I
understood them down in the next
paragraph that says in January he
learned that the Israelis responding to
urgent entreaties from the Iranians had
used the proprietary to transport 18
Hawk missiles to Iran not factual it's
not factual because many people in the
US government had known that they were
Hawk missiles in November when they were
being shipped is that correct absolutely
now when Colonel North told you twice
that mr. McFarlane had drafted the
second version of the chronology did you
understand him to be asserting that the
draft was true I understood him to be
saying that the that the principal
officer who dealt with the President on
this matter had drafted the language and
that was the view that he was putting
forward of the facts there's not
consistent with my understand the facts
moreover I like to say that in my view
as I said as I've said many times later
this was a non-issue I couldn't
understand this it was a non-issue in my
judgment on whether the president
approved beforehand or after hand who
cares you know it seemed to me to be at
a not very important issue that was
becoming for some reason an important
issue in any event when mr. North said
to you what he did you you no longer
continue to read the chronology you
simply got on the Left yes sir
mr. chairman I asked that exhibit number
seven the various documents which have
been marked exhibit number seven be made
a part of the record of this hearing
there since order to see Court that you
at any time
shred any documents relating to the
Iranian initiative or to the Nicaraguan
project that you were working on I had
some telephone logs shredded and some
telexes shredded they're related to the
Contra affair nothing that related to
the Iranian why did she do that and why
I did it because I was growing
increasingly concerned about the
tremendous amount of information being
printed and printed in the press linking
us to in my office specifically to the
Contra airlift operation there had been
telephone supposed telephone records in
El Salvador handed over to the press in
which my office number was listed along
with some other telephone numbers as
frequently called numbers here in
Washington I was a concern that that my
office is very insecure doesn't make
special security equipment that in a
break-in people would would grab my
telephone logs and we had old logs
they're going back over
a long time and it occurred and this
occurred in I believe in early November
because I was about the time the
publicity was I was becoming bad so I
didn't I was trying to conceal any
documentary evidence that one could get
their hands on that would link us to the
Contras you say you were trying to
conceal it from anyone who broke in yes
and I didn't need those documents so I
mean they were all dated so we got rid
of them exactly what documents were they
old telephone logs copies of telephone
messages that have been left over a year
and a half or two year period thus all
the telephone numbers of the people we
do business with all over the world were
in there I didn't want those coming out
not to be harassed and then there were
some telexes with the Arms Company and
Portugal which I also did not want to be
publicized and had them and I didn't
need them so they were destroyed did you
destroy any other documents than the
ones you've just described I don't
remember any other documents being
destroyed at that time or any other time
did you destroy any documents after mr.
Mises press conference no did you
destroy any documents after you had
received or your company had received
any subpoena or official requests for
documents no we delivered all our
documents mr. seacord did you receive
any money personally out of the Iran
initiative the only money that I
received personally was my salary from
Stanford technology and how much was
that six thousand dollars a month did
you receive any other money at all out
of the Iranian initiative initiative no
I did not I I told you that I for swore
my share of the earlier prophets and
and there were there were no profits
given to me earlier prophets refer to
the arms broker brokering that took
place in 1985 did that have anything to
do with the Iranian initiative to begin
with no was there was it ever call your
question was irani an initiative oh yes
you're right
the answer is no was it ever
contemplated that you would obtain
profits or any other kind of
remuneration in connection with the
Iranian initiative no and there was no
profit motivation in this Iranian
initiative we did not price these
weapons to generate personal profits you
know we didn't have in mind a personal
profit residue of any kind in this
operation we priced in to create
operational of revenue we we needed
money to operate this thing the US
government did not provide one nickel
for this operation I was expected to
raise the money to run the operation all
of it this is what the government
expected me to do we cut the price on
our last transaction down to a very low
price for these toes because we felt at
that time we had sufficient pool of
money for continuing operations and this
operation was aborted and the residue
that you see there the eight million
dollars it's still in deposit is is on
deposit because we didn't take any the
money was any of the money from the
Iranian initiative set aside for you
know was any of it set aside on the
books of mr. Hakim for you not as far as
I know where was any of it set aside on
books being handled on mr. Hakeem's
behalf for you know and when we look
through mr. Hakeem's records we couldn't
identify any such accounts mr. seacord
the Senate committee is in litigation
with you attempting to compel a waiver
of
foreign bank secrecy requirements so far
you have prevailed in that in that
litigation but since then you have made
a decision to come forward and testify
without immunity will you at this time
subsequent to that decision to testify
voluntarily will you voluntarily execute
the waivers that you have previously
been asked to well I'm inclined to sign
such a waiver mr. Nields and I probably
will but I reserve the right to consult
on this complex matter with my counsel
first and we'll be in touch with you now
are you willing to provide the
committee's with all of your tax returns
and related financial information yeah
I've already provided you with the tax
returns and any other financial
statements information you wish I would
be happy to give you to Secord these I
think you've testified that the three
transactions with Iran threw off a
surplus when you take the price received
and deduct the aggregate cost of goods
plus expenses you've testified that it
threw off an aggregate surplus of
fourteen million dollars my question to
you sir is whose money was that well
that's an interesting question mr.
Nields and it said it say excuse me one
minute mr.
the the number 14 million is not the the
relevant number the the number that's
relevant to your question I believe is
the eight million dollars that's in
these accounts right now let me make it
perfectly clear mr. seacord I'm not
asking you you you may answer this later
but my question now is at the time the
surplus was created whose money wasn't
was the enterprise's money that was
there for continuing operations who
decided and who was entitled to decide
how it would be spent these decisions
were being made by me and they were
being relayed to mr. Hakim who who
implemented the decisions are you
asserting mr. seacord that you were
entitled to decide to use that money for
any purpose that you wanted yes yeah
some of the money was used to buy a boat
that correct correct that was done at
mr. North's request yes for a u.s.
requirement and that was for a
governmental purpose yes
some money was spent to buy motorola
radios yes that was at mr. North's
direction and his request and that was
for a governmental purpose I think it
was for a and purpose it was in form of
a donation to a foreign government yes
was this something that mr. North wanted
to do to satisfy himself personally or
was there some official purpose to
giving a donation to a barn I think
government I think he'd had some
requests for assistance from
the US representative in this country
well did you understand that he was
acting in his official capacity or some
personal capacity when he asked you to
give money to this Caribbean country I
always understood him to be in his
official capacity so you understood this
to be a governmental request that's a
that's a hard question I didn't think of
it in that in that way but I suppose the
answer is basically yes and mr. North
asked you to give him some cash that he
could give to some DEA agents yes we we
gave cash to him for that purpose and
also we gave it directly to the DEA DEA
agents and that was a governmental
purpose yes and a lot of the money was
spent on Iran expenses correct and that
was a governmental purpose yes sir
and money was spent on the Contras yes
that was also at mr. North's request his
suggestion well I think you indicated he
did more than suggest he urged you can
continually as I understand it he urged
me to do it but it was my decision and
as I testified earlier we didn't always
send as much money as he thought we
should now you you've asserted a moment
ago that in spite of the fact that you
were using the money for governmental
purposes that mr. North's request that
you were entitled to take all of the
money fourteen million dollars and spend
it for any personal purpose that you
wished I didn't say personal purpose you
asked if I could spend it for any
purpose I wished and and my answer
technically is yes including a personal
purpose we never never never
contemplated such a thing never were you
entitled to use it for a personal
purpose in my opinion yes so you could
have gone off and bought an island in
the Mediterranean with the 14 million
dollars yes mr. Nields but I did not go
to them
and I guess I'm trying to make the point
that you know the money's still there
mr. Nields
it's still there it's intact was was
this expressed in writing anywhere no
sir this was a covert operation and was
being run under my direction mr. Hakim
followed my guidance or was this a
covert operation of the US government it
was it it was in support of a US
government covert operation and I tried
to use covert tactics in order to
support that operation but in any event
there was nothing in writing that
expressed your entitlement to use this
money for any purpose you wished no
there was nothing in writing which
prohibited either did you have any
discussions with Colonel North or anyone
else in the US government which in which
they agreed to such an arrangement the
there were a lot of lawyers in the room
in the Situation Room when we were
discussing the finding in January of
1986 and my role was laid out as that of
the commercial cut out none of these
lawyers told me that was anything other
than a commercial operator no these
lawyers told me that I was a government
agent I wasn't being paid a government
salary I didn't get a nickel of
government money I did not think of
myself conceived myself as a government
person I was a private person trying to
help my government well in the letter
which I think has been marked Exhibit
one signed by Oliver North it states
that you're discreet as assistances
again required in support of our
national interests right did you
understand that you were performing
functions in the national interest or in
your personal interest I was performing
functions privately in the national
interest and you assert that you were
entitled to use the the money generated
from the sale of US military equipment
for your own personal purposes I didn't
say that I said that technically that
that could have been done that's you
know that's a hypothetical question
because of nothing like that was done
now I take it that the the money that
came into these Swiss accounts was the
purchase price for
military equipment in US stocks is that
correct that's that was correct in fact
that last part that's that's partly
correct the money that came into the
Swiss accounts was intended to procure
the equipment and to transport the
equipment to Iran well it was the
purchase price that
gorban Ofra was paying for the arms yes
and he was paying for arms that were in
US government stocks the government
could have charged anything they wanted
to for these for these weapons the
government charged what they thought
they were supposed to charge and I own
the government my only question was were
these arms in US government stocks yes
and indeed the price was paid before
those arms left US government stocks
that's right that was a requirement
that's correct
and Colonel North was the government
official who decided how much money
would be charged to korban affairs and
that also true Colonel North decided how
much that's my question no I decided how
much we would charge did you do that in
conjunction with Colonel North I had to
because he was getting basic prices for
me well also Colonel North knew what the
price was going to be before he decided
whether the government would sell the
arms it's not right he didn't decide
what the government would sell those
arms for the Pentagon did he relayed
that information to me after was relayed
to him by CIA logisticians well mr.
seacord this was an important government
project that you were working on was it
not yes
and of the price that was being charged
to the Iranians wasn't an important fact
in that project wasn't it it was a very
important fact to me if I didn't have
sufficient funds to operate the
enterprise with it couldn't be done well
it was important in another way wasn't
it if you charged too much it could
jeopardize the whole program yes but
that was never never a factor well it
was a factor was it not in the fact that
the program eventually fell apart I
don't believe that the program fell
apart because of the dispute over the
microfiche list when we discussed this
matter with the second Channel they said
that it was not an issue not an
important issue
well mr. gorban afar was quite unhappy
about the price that was being charged
because mr. gorban ipar was being
deceptive with us and was dealing with
Finn and Sears he had told me that he
was dealing with Iranian money and he
was not and so he got he got himself
painted into a corner
well eventually I think according to
your prior testimony he claimed that he
had never been fully paid for the for
the arms and consequently had not been
able to reimburse mr. Khashoggi and mr.
Khashoggi threatened to expose the
entire operation that's correct and mr.
gorban affair was eventually extremely
unhappy and there was a leak and the
operation was exposed that is also
correct wouldn't you agree that that the
price charged if too high a price had
been charged that was a fact which which
could jeopardize the entire operation if
too high a price were charged it could
jeopardize the operation but too high a
price was not charged but what I'm
asking is wasn't it a question that the
u.s. government had an interest in well
looking back at it I suppose you could
say that but I don't recall any
discussions about that factor at that
time was there ever a price charge that
Colonel North was not aware of in
advance
no because I informed him completely on
everything that we did and was there
ever a price charge that he didn't agree
with no but you're asserting that you
had the power to decide to what price to
charge and to keep the difference
between whatever price you charged and
the and the price paid to the US
government plus expenses that's correct
in your opening statement you made a
reference to mr. Attorney General Mises
statement on the 25th of November 1986
right and I think you had some
uncomplimentary things to say about the
statement what was it that you objected
to in it when I learned that the
investigate an internal inquiry was
going on I was I was fearful that there
would be a rush to judgment and I asked
my attorney mr. green to go and lay out
the outlines of this operation to the
Justice Department to mr. Brewer to the
number-two man and then investigation
Bradford Reynolds mr. green was not
aware of any of the details of the
Iranian operation he wasn't aware there
was such a thing until about this time
just shortly before this time and I had
to hurriedly give him a briefing myself
but he did go and talk on two days for
two days Monday and Tuesday that would
have been the 24th and the 25th of
November and on the 25th of November mr.
Reynolds informed him mr. green that he
agreed with mr. greens thrust which was
that we should slow down take this thing
a step at a time we'll lay it out for
you give you all the details that we can
we should not rush into out into the
public with this story until you at
least have the facts you couldn't
possibly have ascertained the facts in a
weekend investigation mr. Reynolds
agreed but minutes later obviously
unbeknownst to mr. Reynolds mr. Meese
went before the American people and made
his pronouncements and betrayed all of
us and it's unforgivable
what else did you do or what did you do
with anything after he made the
announcement well I was stunned just you
you mean just before he made the
announcement or just after well I think
it was just after did that come a time
when you made a call to Admiral
Poindexter
yes sir but it was just before the
announcement that morning I had heard
because I'd received a call from Norris
office in fact I received two calls from
there that at the National Security
Adviser
Poindexter was resigning and that North
was also resigning that's what they said
I called Poindexter was difficult for me
to get through but I insisted and I was
rude in getting through
I asked John what in the world is going
on he said that it was too late I was
try was it was my intention to urge him
not to not to quit but to stand in there
and fight let's get this thing
straightened out but he said it's too
late the resignation had already gone
forward and I said I said well denied I
want to talk to the president personally
myself I insist on it and I told his
aide that I demanded to talk to the
president he said it was too late they'd
already built a wall around the
president I was very very frustrated but
time was rushing forward and shortly
after my brief conversation with with
John Poindexter mr. Meese made his
announce his announcement did you on
another occasion
thus it later in the same day after the
announcement make a request to speak to
the president
they reframe the question were you an
oliver north together later on in the
day in a hotel oh yes yes
by this time my office was just
untenable the press were besieging it
and so I went to a nearby hotel for a
few hours to consult with with my
attorney and Oliver North came to the
hotel
and I presume that what you're getting
at is the telephone conversation that
was received a telephone call that was
received I take it there was a telephone
call received while you were there yes
for whom the call came in for there were
two phone calls that came in before
Colonel North one call was from the
president I didn't realize it was the
president for a few seconds until I saw
him stand up at attention he's a good
marine you know and he said yes mr.
president yes mr. president thank you
very much mr. president and then he said
that I'm just sorry I've had to end this
way I was trying to serve you the best
way I knew how
mr. president I said let me have the
phone but it was too late he hung up I
didn't I wasn't fast enough
what was it you wanted to tell the
president I wanted to tell the president
that I'd like to seem and try to bring
some rationality back into this into
this matter there's no there's no
there's no reason to back away from
these operations I mean maybe there were
mistaken judgments taken in the policy
maybe not I happen to think that it was
a good policy and was worth the worth a
try but in any case once you've made a
decision like this to back away from it
it is a terrible mistake in my judgment
they are defensible the American people
would understand the rationale that
underlie such a policy and we've done
nothing wrong moreover in trying to
privately support the the Contras that
we've we've not broken any law
especially we have not we were a
situation making sure that we didn't
violate any law pertaining to the
Contras and then I have in mind the
Boland Amendment when I'm speaking to
this the Iranian initiative was
completely legal
lawyers worked on that hard
a press conference of that day the
so-called diversion the use of Iranian
arms sales proceeds
and we made some progress in both areas
some credit could be taken it seemed to
me and so my my advice would have been
let's take out our position don't cut
and run I didn't get a chance to make
that kind of a speech I missed one make
it now mr. Meese had emphasized in his
press conference of that day the
so-called diversion the use of Iranian
arms sales proceeds for the Contras what
was your understanding of the
president's knowledge of that issue and
what was your basis for it well I have
no direct first-hand knowledge about
what the president knew or didn't know
as I think everyone knows I never spoke
with the President on this I was told on
a number of occasions and I even
recorded at once in a December 1984 memo
to myself that the president was
informed of my participation in the
Contra and later in the seat in the
Iranian operations you know I had talked
with the director of the CIA who was a
close confident of the president I
assumed that that he was passing
information to him I talked with two
different national security advisors
during the two years in question here I
vetted all the projects I was working on
with Oliver North and I was told by
Admiral Poindexter in January of 86 that
not only was he pleased with the work
that I've been doing but the president
was as well and on a few occasions I
heard Oliver North in an offhand and I
think humorous vein remarked that in
some conversations with the president he
had mentioned that it was very ironic
that some of the ayatollahs money was
being used to support the Contras
whether he was whether he actually said
that he in a way that I took it as a
joke say it was not said in a way that
you took it as a joke I did not take it
as a joke earlier you said that when you
were in the room in which they were
working on the finding you said that the
Israelis roll in
this transaction was to provide the
cover and if there was an exposure to
take the hit what did you mean well
they're Israelis played an important
role in this and they were as I said
joint venture partners but one role
which was fairly clear to me was that in
this covert operation at least the first
level of deniability normally you have
different levels of cover involved in a
covert operation and if a certain amount
of exposure resulted the first level of
deniability or protection for the United
States if you will could be that the
Israelis would take the blame for the
shipments in other words that the
Israelis would say it was the Israelis
who were shipping the arms to Iran this
was an option that was available now
that would have meant then that it would
have been the American people in the
Congress who would not have found out
that arms were shipped to Iran by this
country if if such an option were
exercised that's true that option was
never exercised mr. chairman I have no
further questions of mr. seacord at this
time thank you very much mr. O'Neill
[Music]
I took it serious okay
general Secord I want to begin this
afternoon by confirming a few
biographical details for the record if I
mind
I understand sir that you flew more than
250 combat missions in Southeast Asia is
that correct yes I further understand
that you received a number of
decorations including the Distinguished
Service Medal the Legion of Merit the
Distinguished Service Cross among others
is that correct yes sir I understand
that during your Air Force flying career
you had more than 4,500 flying hours is
that correct yes I understand that
during your service in Iran you directed
the military assistance advisory group
for the Air Force which meant that you
managed all Air Force and some army and
navy security programs as well is that
correct
security assistance programs right you
lived in Iran for more than four years
as I understand it yes sir and you speak
some Farsi I can understand more than I
can speak that I was tutored in in Farsi
some years ago did you serve as the
deputy commander of the Carter
Administration hostage rescue task force
created after desert one yes but that
was the one created after desert one I
did not participate in the desert one
raid right but the task force that was
created after desert one I was the
deputy commander that was the deputy
Task Force commander and the air
commander and after your retirement in
1983 and from then until 1985 did you
serve without pay on a panel which
directly advises the Secretary of
Defense and is known as the Special
Operations Advisory Group yes sir
okay with that as a pro you'd let me
start my substantive questions with
questions related to your involvement
with the Contras according to your prior
testimony in about July 1984 you
to become involved in supporting the
Contra resistance operation at the
request of Colonel north why did Colonel
North approached you for assistance if
you know I was only one of a number of
people I believe he approached for
assistance he was trying to mobilize
private individuals to do what they
could to support the contrary effort any
other particular reason why he might
have approached you well he knew of me
from my prior service he'd observed me
in operation on a number of occasions I
guess and and thought and knew that I
was a special operations experienced
person and thought that I would be one
of several who might be interested over
time and particularly after mid nineteen
eighty five did you become familiar with
many aspects of the Contra resistance
yes please tell the committee if you
would about the human aspects of the
situation in the Contras in 1985 and
1986 what were the day-to-day living
conditions of the Contras as they
reported to you during but as they were
reported to you during that period
well the Contras were suffering they
were short of money for food and had
inadequate clothing and inadequate
shelter especially the families living
mainly in Honduras along the border area
the troops themselves though were not
well equipped they were often without
boots they their clothing was often
inadequate they didn't have Poncho's I
mean they were short of everything that
soldiers need they were very very short
on money thank you
you testified earlier than in early July
1985 you attended a meeting in Miami at
the request of Colonel north at that
meeting you participated in a program
review of the Contra heifer looking back
to that period what did that program
review reveal with respect to the
military situation
of the Contras at that time I think the
military situation was very bad at that
time and it was likely to get worse I
testified I think to my belief that if
an airlift operation were not formed and
put into operation fairly quickly they
would not be able to sustain themselves
in the field and they were going to be
defeated in detail you told the
committee that not long after the July
1985 Miami meeting you decided you would
be willing to participate in an airlift
operation to support the Contras I have
several questions in this regard first
could you explain why you were willing
to participate in this operation you
served essentially as a volunteer as I
understand it only because it was judged
to be absolutely vital to get it going
and no one else seemed to be able to get
it going so and I by this time I think I
had the the trust of a number of the key
players and so I pressed ahead I also
told you I think that my close
colleagues advised me against doing it
because they were afraid of the
consequences on a related matter you
testified yesterday that you believed
you might be able to return to a
high-level government position did
anyone in the United States government
tell you that no this was my this was my
own estimate and my estimate of the
administration at that time did anyone
in the United States government imply to
you that you might receive a position in
return for your work with the contrast
nope
as I understand it in late 1985 you
obtained a legal opinion from patton
boggs and blow of washington law firm in
connection with the planning for the
proposed airlift in 1985 is that correct
yes I was concerned about impossible
violation of the neutrality act and I
had to have a legal opinion before I
would go forward what did you do with
that opinion once you had obtained it
well I provided copies to the several
people who were to become involved mr.
gad was the first one that I discussed
it with and and all other principle
principles in the operation as time went
on I wanted to make sure that everybody
knew that we were conducting a lawful
operation and that we would have to
assiduously comply with the law one of
the operational restrictions that that
imposed was that we could not transport
any contra personnel and we did not I
believe you testified yesterday that
during your participation in the
contrary left operation no weapons of
any type were shipped from the United
States is that correct
that's absolutely correct why is that
fact important well the US has very
strict weapons export laws which I was
aware of and did not want to have to be
requesting export licenses from the US
government for the Contras somehow I
thought they might not be approved again
in connection with the airlift operation
you testified yesterday that you
received support from certain United
States government officials in
connection with your work on the
contrary airlift program yet I believe
you also testified that in some cases
you didn't get the support you asked for
and that in other cases you got moral
support but no material support at all
to assure that the record is clear I
would like to review with you the
individuals you named or described by
position yesterday other than Oliver
North and asked you to tell the
committee specifically what type and
amount of support your operation got
from those officials okay
Director of Central Intelligence Casey I
made request of him as I testified for
intelligence information support he made
no commitments to me and then whatever
he said he would look into it
I see so again so my question is clear
then specifically what type and amount
of support would you say that you did
receive from director Casey well I think
that we understand that he supported
what you were doing just as a general
political proposition but what type of
support do you think you actually got I
think that he conferred with some of his
senior officers and asked them to
support us as much as he viewed the law
would permit to give us some support but
not to give us any material support or
material I should say support and you
think of specific examples of the type
of support that might have been
permitted that you believe you got I
really after Casey's action I believed
that I was entitled to the operation was
entitled to good intelligence
information support and weather
information support - those were the two
items that that we really needed most we
did not get the kind of support we
needed we got some support the United
States Ambassador to Costa Rica what
type of support specifically did you
receive from him we received guidance I
think from him and support with the
friendly foreign government there the
Costa Rican government in the matter of
procuring the land that we procured and
in the subsequent construction of the
airstrip there the United States
ambassador to El Salvador yes what type
of
I can't say that we had anything other
than moral support from from him he I
did speak with him personally during my
brief trip to El Salvador in April of 86
I know that he was sympathetic with our
operation and I know that he kept track
of it anything further know his senior
Central Intelligence Agency official in
Honduras yes what type of support about
the only support we received from him
was a occasional intervention with the
fdn officials of when we were trying to
get some supplies from them to drop to
the southern front
a senior Central Intelligence Agency
official in Costa Rica yes we got most
of our support from this individual he
is a visible OTT of praise he had very
little staff and he worked very hard
himself to try to keep us as informed as
possible and to forward as much
information to us as he could even
though our communication system was not
very good general without no one I
caution you here and elsewhere not to
reveal any intelligence source or method
but can you be more specific about
precisely what type of support you
receive from this official we received
intelligence information support in the
form of order of battle information and
disposition of friendly and enemy troops
to the to the extent that he had such
information on a continuing basis or
intermittently once once we got our act
together and started dropping on a
reasonably sustained basis so it was a
very frequent communications contact and
he had face-to-face contact with my man
mr. Quintero from time to time if I
understood you correctly earlier you
believed that under the law you were
eligible in effect to receive that type
of intelligence information is that
correct that's correct
thank you Colonel James Steele yes the
military group commander in El Salvador
as I mentioned Colonel Steele was a very
supportive of us he gave our people a
lot of good guidance and information he
was supportive of our cause with the
local military commanders which was a
very valuable assistance for us he was
unable to provide us with any material
support including intelligence support
his rule simply would not permit it and
he made that clear to us were there any
other United States government officials
who provided support for your operation
other than oliver north as we said not
that I can think of thank you I'd like
to ask you now to turn to the exhibit
book I believe you have a copy of at
your table and to look at exhibit number
three if you would please okay I like
you to start with the document that I
believe is marked number one in the
upper right hand corner it's dated March
3rd 1986 assuming it was transcribed on
the same day that it was sent you have
that document yes
can you describe just in general terms
the I take it that what is happening
here is that certain United States
government officials are refusing to
cooperate in some respect with the
operation that that you're conducting is
and in general terms is that what's
happening here no not really this was a
problem with a by foreign country who
was saying that they would have to have
United Kingdom or at least short
brothers I'm sorry but I should general
I think you may have the wrong document
it's got a small number one
in the upper right hand corner in the
latest March 3rd 1986 got you I'm with
you the thrust of this is maybe I wasn't
feeling too good that day but the thrust
of this is that there were some
bureaucratic impediments being placed in
mr. God's way and it didn't make any
sense and I was appealing to North's
office to see if they couldn't help him
out
could I ask you to turn now in that same
exhibit police general to the document
that has a number 19 in the upper
right-hand corner the date if I'm
reading this correctly would be May 21st
1986 could you take a moment to review
that what's the date May 21st 1986
yes I have it okay it begins our
understanding and then it says CAI you
have that document could you take a
moment and just review that please and
then describe to us who sent the message
who it was to and and what is happening
there
I believe that this was a message that
was sent to me from mr. Quintero and and
can you tell us as you understand it
what mr. Quintero was reporting to you
what did what had happened why did it
happen and so on if you'd go through it
in some detail I'd appreciate it
he was reporting that the US officials
with whom we had the occasional contact
were saying that they could no longer
speak to any of our people on
operational matters including mr.
Quintero and he said that this
especially applied to the senior CI
official in Costa Rica on whom we were
relying for information he was very
concerned about this very concerned he
commented that he didn't know what
Colonel Steele's role would be in the
future of course Colonel Steele's chain
of command was somewhat different in he
hadn't had I don't think he'd really had
a chance to talk with you and then he
speculates I don't know whether it's
correct or not but he speculates that
there had been some new interpretation
of the law which required them to issue
new orders to the field but he doesn't
know that he speculates alright and the
last sentence if I might says no you
have some concern for officers well let
me take the the sentence prior to that
says evidently CIA has done much
discussing with Washington lawyers on
this and are concerned with their legal
status in this program so actually the
overall subject is the question of what
guidelines should apply to the
assistance that was going to be
available and says no you have same
concern for our position but can work
out with good could you shed any light
on that last sentence for us he's saying
that he he believes that I have the same
can I will have the same concern that he
has just passed forward and he's
wondering if I can't get in touch with
Colonel North that's good
find out what's going on let's see if we
couldn't you know get to get the
straight word and did you pursue that
with Colonel north yes I did and and he
he didn't understand it either at the
time but I was told later that for a
while there in the CI system there was a
considerable drawing back away from
dealing with us at all
in the early of the matter but then that
that period passed fairly rapidly okay
could you turn please to the document
that has the number 25 in the upper
right hand corner it's actually a set of
three Cal forty three messages on the
same page and okay I believe them
although it's a little bit difficult to
read these are dated in August probably
of 1986
have you found that page yes could I ask
you please to review the KL 43 message
that is the third of the three messages
the one down at the bottom of the page
and please read through that and I'd
like to ask a couple of questions back
okay
could you describe again go through it
in some detail and describe for us
exactly what to your understanding is
happening here this message relates to
the other messages on that page and this
is Bob Burrell in Norris office in a
message to robert dutton in my office
saying that the the situation about
which we were complaining in el salvador
was such that was being was being
affected among other things by some new
order by the DCI to his people in the
field saying that they couldn't deal
with us i think he was asking he was
thinking that we were asking them to
intercede with CIA to help us but we
were not because they they couldn't have
helped us in salvador anyway but he goes
on to say that he got a report that he
got the word that Colonel Steele who is
who had been visiting here in Washington
would not meet with my man Colonel
Dutton and supposedly at the direction
of the Ambassador I don't know if that's
factual or not but it relates all to
this problem we were having at the
airbase in El Salvador and in our
attempt to resolve the issue it appears
as though what is being said here is
that various United States officials
have been told explicitly or implicitly
not to assist you in resolving that
problem that's that's what he's saying
thank you
can you again without revealing any
intelligence information describe where
the the tapes that are used to operate a
KL 43 come from that is they come for
the United States government agents who
don't come from a government agency and
they were distributed to us I'm they
they ago are these these operate on a
monthly basis and they were distributed
to us on a monthly basis from Colonel
Norris office I take it they're not the
sort of thing that one can buy at
RadioShack is that correct no they're
very sensitive and they have to be you
have to be very careful about security
of these items based on your experience
with the Contra airlift operation were
the governments of the various Central
American countries in which your
officials which your employees worked
concerned about the threat to their
countries posed by the Sandinistas
indeed that's why the officials in
Salvador were so supportive of this
operation I did I saw it and their
interest it wasn't that they were just
trying to do us a favor would that be
had been generally true for example in
Costa Rica in connection with the
airstrip well we thought it was true was
one government but then I've been the
policy of neutrality hardened with the
with the new government that came in
last year and so we we did not get the
kind of support we thought we were going
to get but as a general matter if you
were operating in a particular country
it was because they perceived that you
had a common interest with them or in
dealing with the sandanista indeed of
course we couldn't have operated
otherwise thank you I believe you
testified yesterday that Felix Rodriguez
came to Washington in August 1986 and
met with
Donald Gregg to complain among other
things to complain about your operation
is is that correct yes well he came the
purpose of the extensible purpose of his
visit was to to get with Colonel north
and and Robert Dutton and try to thrash
out this problem that had erupted down
there but after that meeting he did go
to visit with Donald Gregg and and he
did visit with the vice president as has
been publicized many times and did come
make a number of allegations about the
quality of our operation that that
actually gets to the point I wanted to
ask you about what is the basis of your
statement that Rodriguez met with the
vice president during that trip my man
Dutton accompanied him as far as their
office do you have any way to know what
might have been discussed between
Rodriguez and the vice president if in
fact they meant only from comments later
by Oliver North who did talk with mr.
Gregg or so he said and got got the list
of allegations as a result of a racist
meeting with Gregg or his meeting with
the vice president well I think I said I
don't know what he said to the vice
president were you ever given an account
of that meeting no sir okay so you have
no way of knowing what if anything was
during that meeting is that correct no
way whatsoever of knowing okay thank you
but you are it was reported to you that
they did in fact meet yes
other than his United States government
salary and any possible reimbursement
for expenses for official business which
he may have received to your knowledge
did Oliver North receive any personal
profits from the Iran arms sales no he
did not did he receive any such profits
from contributions to the Contras not a
smaller source not as far as I know
Oliver North was a very honorable man he
is a very honorable
to your knowledge other than through a
salary or a predetermined commission or
profit share did any of the following
individuals derive personal profits from
the Iran arms sales and I'll just I'm
gonna go through a list here and ask you
to answer as you go along
Thomas Klein's did he receive did he
receive personal profits other than a
predetermined Commission or profit share
or salary he did not for essence when he
went to a Cyprus he received no
compensation
Ralf Quintero no Robert Dutton
no Richard Gott no Albert Hakim No
that he said other than predetermined
profits ooh yes but the question was
other than a predetermined Commissioner
profit share
madam clerk or banner farm I haven't I
have no no information on on what he did
or how I did it I am sure I am aware
that he made profits but I can't
quantify it
yakov numero d the same applies there I
like I have no knowledge of what kind of
profits he made I cannot put a number to
it else former this time like to ask you
to look at the document with the number
27 in exhibit 3 years
[Applause]
I think I have it do you have a date yes
I think this is the one that has up in
the top and handwriting a steel 8 August
and down in the text it's a KL 43
message I believe it's dated August 8
1986 I have it down toward the lower
third of the document there is a
sentence that reads as follows we must
be very smart about our procedures sure
press and others will be watching and we
don't wish to expose non USG efforts
right I tell you my recollection is you
testified you wrote that no no I did not
if I said that I misspoke this is from
Macalester who is Dutton okay and it's
going to it's I believe this to me he's
he is
I believe standing me the message okay
no I think you just found yesterday that
this was a non United States government
operation correct a wholly private
operation correct if this operation was
legal as you testified why was it
necessary to keep its existence a secret
because the there was my judgment and
the judgment of my colleagues that the
that the press the news media would
savages
so the concern you had as far as secrecy
was purely a result of your concern
about the press absolutely for instance
the press even now is talking about
violations of the Boland Amendment and
that they haven't the people who are
doing this writing haven't even taken
the time to write her study the law and
so when you have to deal with that kind
of a press you have to be very careful
did Oliver North or any other United
States government official ever tell you
to keep this operation secret
no but they assumed that it would be
kept secret
couldn't it couldn't be operated
otherwise could you explain why it could
not have been operated except in secret
please because I as I said earlier it
was our judgment that the press would
cause so much trouble for us that we
couldn't we could not operate it surely
you didn't expect the press to directly
interfere in your operation sure I
expected them to directly interfere in
it yes could you be more specific they
would be all over the the quarters where
the as they were later just they would
do just exactly what they did when the
when the operation started John rabble
after the shoot-down of the c-123 and
they would be all over our operational
sites and they would also cause problems
of embarrassment for our hosts as well
because the hosts certainly did not want
it to be known that we were there so if
I understand your testimony correctly
and I want to make sure that I do you're
suggesting that you were concerned about
physical interference with your
operations by the press to an extent
that I was most concerned about what
they would publish what they would write
about and say on television in this if
we became an embarrassment we would not
be allowed in that country very long an
embarrassment to the host countries in
which our history we're concerned about
the possibility that if the press became
aware of the operation that would mean
that Congress would become aware of it
as well no I didn't even think of the
Congress in this context because I was
quite certain and satisfied they were
operating completely legally so I was
not concerned about the US Congress did
you ever tell Oliver North or any other
White House official that in response to
a congressional request for information
the White House should tell Congress
about the private airlift operation and
the nature of White House support for it
I don't recall that subject ever coming
out did you ever discuss with with
Colonel North or anyone else at the
White House any congressional requests
for information concerning the
activities of the National Security
Council not not with any specificity I
can I can vaguely recall him worrying as
I've testified about investigations or
inquiries by the Congress I can recall
him being concerned that the the
Congress would be pursuing him and I'm
trying to paint him as being in
violation of Boland Amendment for
instance he was he was worried about
that but my my view of Colonel know
Colonel North was that he was doing
everything he could to implement Boland
Amendment everything he could I have a
general that my question to you was did
you ever discuss a congressional
requests for information concerning the
activities of the National Security
Council with Colonel North no not that I
can recall did you ever recommend to him
on any other occasion that Congress
should be told about the private airlift
operation and the nature of White House
support for it no either either I might
add publicly or through the
public publicly yes later later on in
starting in the summer of 86 when I
became concerned about possible
revelations of the Iran operation I
urged him a number of occasions to
consider to take up with his bosses a
preemption on the part of the White
House that is to go public and in an in
going public
of course I think they would have been
addressing in my mind the Iranian
initiative only but our operation that
might have been revealed also our contra
operation to your knowledge other than
some part of the salaries and
administrative expenses of the federal
officials you have previously told the
committee provided support for your
airlift operation where any other funds
appropriated by Congress used for the
private airlift operation no absolutely
not did you want to add something
general well I'm not I'm not even
prepared to concede that that their
salaries were an issue here either but
they you know there were no appropriated
funds used to support our operation okay
in your opening statement you referred
to the vital interests of the United
States in containment of the Sandinista
regime would you please describe for the
committee the strategic significance of
Central America and in particular of
Nicaragua as you understand it is
specifically okay briefly I can say a
few things I think I'm not an expert on
on Central America but I know enough
about warfare to know that the situation
in Nicaragua represents a terrible
threat to the United States the whole
the the nations of the Caribbean Basin
are very very fragile nations and many
of them struggling for democracy right
now and they all need US military and
economic support but the Russians as
some members have pointed out have
already got a beachhead if you will in
nickel
but today the there is no question no
question in my mind that if the
Sandinistas government is allowed to
continue in power that they will be
trying to export their revolution to its
to their neighbors and I'm not a great
adherent of the domino theory but if
there ever were any dominoes stacked up
in this world they've got to be stacked
up down south of us the bottom line with
me is it's very important to contain
Nicaragua if we if if we can't contain
them down there I think we're in for
more trouble than any of us here can
predict I don't believe I'll hasten to
add that the Contras can win a decisive
military victory I think that the best
outcome they can hope for is to force
some some sort of serious negotiations
with the regime I think that the worst
policy of all for the United States is
to abandon our interests so close to
home and to allow this regime to
continue and one of the things I am
really regretful of with respect to the
iran-contra affair is that I'm I'm very
fearful that that the that this affair
so-called will adversely impact on our
congressmen and Senators and they will
be not inclined to further support the
Contras I'm just praying that that
doesn't happen I'd like to change
subjects with you know a general and in
turn to the Iran initiative itself and
let me begin by cautioning you once
again that in response to the questions
that I'm about to ask you be please be
as careful as you possibly can be not to
reveal any intelligence sources or
methods thank you testified that in 1980
you served as the deputy commander of
the hostage rescue task force
established after the pleasure one like
you - please describe for the committee
during your service on that task force
your efforts to obtain information
concerning the location of the American
hostages who were then held in Iran in
rebuilding or building a task force
capable of going back and rescuing their
own our hostages it turned out very
rapidly that the biggest single problem
we had to confront was the lack of
intelligence information on where they
were being held after desert one
occurred the Iranians we had reports
that the Iranians had dispersed the
hostages who had been held in the main
embassy grounds and dispersed them to
unknown destinations we had hundreds of
reports placing them all over the
country of Iran the reports placing them
just in different places in Tehran and
so this was a of course the highest
priority intelligence target for us was
to locate them I mean we had obviously
had to know where they were if we were
gonna go get them
as time wore on we by August of that
year our force was combat ready and we
were ready to roll but we did not we
were not able to the Intelligence
Committee was not able to pin down the
location of the hostages our
intelligence base at that time by base I
mean data base with respect to Iranian
matters was practically nil it's not
much better today we were of course in
past in contact and liaison with the
Central Intelligence Agency and the
director of Central Intelligence at that
time was Admiral Turner we were pushing
as hard as we could to put more effort
into locating the hostages by October we
were told by a senior official that they
had indeed new information and had low
the hostages the three hostages that
were in the Ministry of Foreign Affairs
were never moved but all of the all the
others had been moved around we were
briefed on this as I said in October of
1980 and I came to call that the Eureka
briefing you know they suddenly found it
we asked about the sources and methods
my intelligence staff of course had no
such holdings and found it a little bit
hard to understand we were denied the
sources and methods and the therefore we
escalated the matter through the chain
of command to the White House and the
the report was not not viewed with favor
when the these people in the hostages
were interviewed in 1981 when they
returned to the United States and
debriefed and debriefed extensively my
intelligence my senior intelligence
staff officer from the task force was
one of those debriefers the report was
incorrect it was absolutely incorrect
where they had them pinned down in the
report they gave us along with photos
was wrong we were given the wrong
location for the hostages that you were
going to try and rescue from harass
absolutely wrong had we gone ahead based
on that I don't think that we've had a
lot of people up here on the hill
applauding us did there come a later
time when as a Department of Defense
official you convinced the Department of
Defense through secretary Weinberger to
urge an improvement in us human
intelligence capabilities in Iran yes a
couple of years later when I was Deputy
Assistant Secretary of Defense my the
region for which I was responsible under
the secretary of defense for policy
matters included Iran and we there came
a time when when we pushed and I pushed
for my staff with the secretary of an
initiative for the CIA to start a
greatly enhanced intelligence gathering
operation
to use and it suggested different
methods which I'm not going to get into
to improve our human intelligence with
respect to Iran
there's just common sense that we need
to know more about the Iran I'm not
saying this in a sinister way it's just
that we don't know very much about these
people are the most of them are
strangers to us we really don't know the
State Department doesn't know the this
information is absolutely necessary
in order for us to formulate any kind of
sane policy with restrict with respect
to Iran we have to know that with whom
we are dealing before we can make any
kind of detailed policy and it's my
judgment then until we get a lot smarter
about Iran we're going to continue to be
in limbo with them and we will never be
able to successfully negotiate with them
and and that that will be that will
redound to our strategic disfavor and
what was the response you got to the
Defense Department proposals from the
Central Intelligence Agency secretary
agreed with our position on this matter
and took it up with mr. casey who agreed
with it but then the bureaucracy took
over and we got into wrangling at the
working level and nothing came of it
nothing came about during the your
involvement in the Iran initiative you
received a number obviously of
intelligence reports this would be in
the period 1985-1986 you received a
number of intelligence reports a number
of intelligence briefings to that
correct I received what they had we were
in close contact with the intelligence
agency right and and in your view had
the quality of our human intelligence
improved since your involvement in 1980
not in the slightest thank you did
United States government officials ever
tell you that you or Albert Hakim or
both of you could personally retain or
put to any use you saw fit part or all
of the proceeds of the United States
arms sold to Iran no if not why didn't
you obtain a legal opinion on this
question as you had on the air left
operation well as I said when I was in
the Situation Room
January or a year ago January in the
room was at a lot of lawyers in there
and was fairly clear they weren't your
lawyers were they Jenna no they were not
my lawyers but it seemed to me that they
had made their mind that this commercial
enterprise was the way to go and that it
was obviously legal now had a provider
to do over again now to get about five
legal opinions if I had it to do over
again I wouldn't do it let's put it that
way but that's hindsight you know I
should have I should have been smarter I
wasn't at the time it simply didn't
occur to you as they were tested not as
a former Department of Defense official
that it seemed natural to you the United
States Department of Defense assets
could be sold to you as a private
middlemen who could then mark them up to
any extent you desired before resale to
the country they were intended to go to
by the United States it seemed to me
that it was legitimate in as much as
they were being sold to the CIA who was
in turn reselling them it would not have
been legal for the Defense Department to
sell them to me but since they were sold
to the CIA your testimony is that they
could then resell them to you as a
private middleman and allow you to mark
them up to any extent you saw fit is
that correct well that's there are two
questions there the the agency lawyers
believe that it was legal to sell them
to me and then of course we didn't mark
them up at any outrageous amount we
marked them up to the prices that were
thought to be the right prices did you
see any potential problem for the
president
if the diversion you've earlier
testified to based on mr. Hakeem's
records were to be disclosed no I really
didn't again maybe I should have been
smarter but I thought that we were
perfectly legitimate in this enterprise
and figured that would be that we would
really be applauded in the end that
issue of diversion was a was a word
coined by mr. Meese not by me and the
so-called diversion when he announced it
I wasn't even sure there had been a
significant diversion because we were
always running very close to the close
to the line
and I wasn't wasn't certain but what it
might have been washed out as it as it
turns out the we calculated recently
that about three and a half or so
million dollars ended up in the contra
project from Iranian derived money
I've always contemplated that more
donations were going to be coming in
during this period I expected that they
would be coming in and the the ten
million dollars that that we were
looking for in the accounts from a from
a Far Eastern country never materialized
but had that come in we would have been
in a surplus position so I believe you
stated that on November 25th you met
with Oliver North in a November 25th
1986 this is you met with Oliver North
in a hotel here in Washington then that
he received a phone call from the
president at that time is that correct
yes sir you testified that he got
another phone call who was the other
call from the first phone call I was
afraid you're gonna ask that I can't
keep any secrets the the first phone
call he received was not from the
president was from the vice president
and the and that my understanding of the
that call was it was essentially the
same kind of laudatory call sad not very
short call
mr. chairman I have no further questions
of this witness Thank You Carol
the procedure at this point normally
would be for counsel for the Senate
committee author Lyman to start the
examination due to the fact that we
would like that examination to be
complete the leadership of the joint
committee has decided that we will
recess the committee's at this time
rather than have a relatively brief
period of examination by mr. Lyman and
general Secord Lu directed to appear
here again tomorrow
with counsel at 10:00 a.m. so under the
agreement of chairman Hamilton and
chairman Inouye congressman Cheney and
myself we have agreed that we will now
stand in recess until 10:00 a.m.
tomorrow Thank You mr. chairman
[Music]